I'd never really played Overwatch 2 that much, but I was a
GM tank in Overwatch 1.
I just like having a really reliable tank.
That makes me more comfortable in any of these kinds of
games, especially more reliable games.
Yeah, no pressure, no pressure.
I played Overwatch 1 when it first came out for like a
couple seasons.
I got top 500 on Ana, Moira, Brickita, and Symmetra.
So like I'm the only one that's like slacking here pretty
much okay got it no wait what oh you so you were around
during goats meta then yeah oh yeah i quit around goat like
i quit around goats yeah i did as well i went to apex after
that yeah i only came yeah i came back for overwatch too for
like one season and i was like all right um all right over
here it's very well too it carries over very very well it's
just it's third person that's really it like it's just okay
what about third person legends any league of legends
knowledges at all like is that just map knowledge like map
awareness that's it
no i'm just saying like is there anything like a good skill
from league that can i guess like probably cool down oh yeah
cool down positioning cool down then you'll be able to play
well should be positioned all right what about valo uh shoot
okay hey guys i woke up you're gonna be just five i might
have three hours of sleep but also it's gonna be a nice
healthy mix of both i will say the team that we're about to
be playing is strong they are dead definitely one of the
stronger rosters, but it's mainly because of Sleepy and
Apply.
Yeah, mainly because of Sleepy and Apply.
They're going to be looking for nano combos with Apply on
DPS.
We're doing the exact same.
So it's going to be essentially a battle of which team gets
the better nano combos.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Well, I think their team is going to get their nano first,
though, just because we're running triple.
It depends on their tanks.
It totally depends on their tanks.
I think Raino is playing Diva.
can pivot to to reaper or bastion just tell me depending on
their tanks right i believe they're on diva i think we stick
the triple support yuzu keep chaining rainho and we just
keep tearing through them like there's no way yeah they
might have maga too because maga's also really strong and i
saw i think i saw rain playing maga earlier really yeah okay
if all right all right here's here's the here's the dilemma
if rain is on mauga then you'll instantly go reaper okay
like next fight like even if you got all charged to swap
over to reaper and just the waste tank we're on the waiting
on your band oh on my band watch this yeah they ban roadhog
widow maker look at this
or you could ban maga you could you could you know you could
ban maga you know he's joking maga would be a great bad no
no no soda's got that under control listen okay i'm not
flaming but a bad malga is the worst teammate you could get
in the game yeah because it's you're missing a tank and a
dps that's true that's true i just i don't know it's been
grinding diva just gonna put that out there 100 i've seen it
i played it for yesterday played it three yesterday for like
five hours so we can do it why don't we just ban diva then
no no rhino doesn't play that much overwatch well they have
they have the drops right you know if we lose if we lose if
we just play our captain it's fine If we lose, we blame our
captain.
Okay, okay.
Should I ban something?
Here, I'll ban something.
I'll ban something.
Ban something.
We can get cocky.
I'm going to ban Kiri.
Kiri's a good ban.
Yeah, that's a good one.
I like that.
Let's make the game fun.
Wait, is Kiri going to be like OP?
Yeah, I mean, I mean, Kiri's just over there.
She's been meta for like 20 years.
That's how OP she is.
They try to nerf her and she'll...
No, they did nerf her.
It's just she's...
Her kid is just too good.
Oh, I thought they buffed her suzu this patch.
I don't know, but I didn't really read this patch notes.
She's actually bugged right now.
Past 20 meters, her heels just don't work.
Oh, nice.
What the hell?
Yeah, who's applying Sleepy going to play?
They're going to be on Shion Ana without a doubt.
Yeah, they're running the same thing as us.
What, are you playing Shion?
Yeah, I'm playing Shion.
The main difference here is we have a Yuzu.
We have a Yuzu.
Yuzu is going to be chaining Reinhardt down to the ground.
It's our tank.
We're going to tank gap them here.
I'm telling you.
I have faith.
Guys, he's overestimating my abilities.
Yeah.
I've seen you hit chains.
I've seen it.
It's all on Yuzu.
No pressure or anything.
But if we lose.
No.
Wait, so hold on a second.
Doki, do you want to be on Ana or Shoto?
Do you want to be on Ana?
I'm down with whatever.
I'll play whatever is most comfortable.
it might be best to have doki on yeah i i would prefer that
for sure since it's a nano game i would rather do the other
healers like alari or um moira okay i feel like alari moira
is pretty like moira you can just chuck your damage orb and
then the lower elo players will not know what to do just be
careful of rainhoe on diva dming your orbs oh guys oh they
did see our team guys because they're waiting for play okay
wait i'm going echo i'm baiting them they can see what we're
playing now oh no we're good no now they can't see it it's
fine switch to symmetra oh connor just keeping us on our
toes i cannot okay let's do this wait mister okay i imagine
that is abdullah okay just making sure we don't have an
imposter no no that's me that's me i like it i like what i
like poke is going to be on all right so make sure you see
yours for that i saw poke pick shion no it's definitely
going to be hazard apply it said in the captain's chat i'm
leaking he said don't ban shion it's the new hero let's have
fun so he's definitely going to be on her yeah i saw i saw
him pick pick shion when we were like waiting for plays is
this best of one oh sorry what'd you say best of one yeah
what is wrong yeah we got to come off like stuff like today
and i was confused guys with our comp we just want to hold
hands do not split so let's go cages left side they follow
follow me i'm gonna die hands everybody come left this is my
first game of the day we're all literally gonna bunker in
this uh room here not move and just oh they're on mezu as
well okay and we're just gonna get inside ready everybody
walk in they have a Mercy pocket with a cast, main.
Tell me, we just got to build up heals on Mizu.
That's the strat here.
Oh, I got killed from Shion.
Don't want to take your time.
Alpha and go on it, right?
Oh, okay.
Apply go crazy on that cast that you.
Yeah, is he the one with the...
I slept with the Mercy pocket.
See, that was the strat I was thinking of.
What if we just pocket you?
True.
We're good.
We'll just have to make sure we're LOSing him so he doesn't
just get free shots on us.
I didn't die.
Yippee.
But you do.
Keep calling your heals like when you're maxed.
Yeah.
Where do we go in one?
Yeah, just main.
Just walk into them.
There's a...
Me too.
No TP.
Yeah, he...
Wait, someone's behind.
It's definitely she on.
I'm on her.
If you can heal me, left.
I'm over.
Tanks.
She on one.
Honey reload.
tanks that we can push we can push yeah we can go left close
left go through the room we're gonna follow our arissa it's
so hard to build my fuels right now yo look at their uh
shion oh they have all up i have a lot here but i'm
reloading i knew oh i got any hills outside mother fucker
that's all right i'm alive i'll leave holy schmoly Okay, I
have ult for the next push.
We'll have our nano-shion combo.
It's good that we see they're not running Ana.
That's gonna help us a lot.
That permanent damage boost.
Alright, let me know when you want it.
I'll play next to Warren.
Yeah, watch out for the Mizuki to our left.
He's looking for free picks.
You're gonna flip her off, Angle.
Yo, I'm ready.
Can you hit me?
Yeah.
She on behind.
Nice.
I slept him.
So I'm trying to get to you.
But we can kill that Arisa.
Make sure we touch point.
Good job.
Left side.
Body blocked your heels.
Okay.
I have alt.
What are we doing first?
I'm going to try to do a better job of calling out their
Zarya's bubbles.
And then we walk in when she has no bubbles.
And we just shoot her.
We're going to have Zarya graph here, guys.
Okay.
We have our Misu wall to put on top of their graph.
So they have she on all a
Watch the cast left side on the mini or that's She on low
Yeah, Zari no personal I'm tied huge on tie Watch the cast
left side left left left Oh, I tried to heal you there It's
okay Oh, they're on the left They're on the left They split
3-3 there I'm splat.
I'm splat.
Playing KDA and playing KDA and playing KDA.
Okay.
Well, it's a hard map.
It's weird to navigate it.
I don't think me living would have done anything anyway.
Okay, what do we have to adjust?
Okay, what we have to adjust is maybe we just walk it.
Their tanks are like a non-issue.
We walk into the cast.
The cast is always off-angling with the mercy, so you guys
just have to be aware at the off-angles.
Yeah, I'm thinking, um, Abdullah, if you see Cass, literally
turn your brain off, our supports are going to follow you
and just, like, walk into him.
I can just focus on healing the tanks, so one of the
supports can just pocket warn.
That's basically it.
That's a good idea, too.
Maybe Yuzu and I play together a little bit more.
So keep tabs on me on Shion.
Oh, okay.
If you can, like, throw me a hat in a 1v1.
They like to split often.
Yeah.
It's just Cass and Mercy splitting.
Exactly.
Yes, one.
Connor and Abdullah, you guys are just going to apply more
pressure on their cast.
It's really important.
He can't kill you guys fast enough if we go on him too
quickly.
And then, Shadow, you can just, like, swap between me and
the...
So he's right side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we heal all of our paths underneath.
I almost got Shion.
No problem.
I can't heal you, Hazu.
Take your time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I got fucked up by 4K.
i'm still a little in right now they realize it oh yeah oh
my goodness oh my goodness we just split there uh he was low
their cast just getting pocketed and uh yeah this is
basically you do you do you want to play juno here so we
could speed ring walk onto the cast he's just out rotating
us right now sure i shouldn't dps or no like okay i think uh
throwing those those um purple orbs might be a good idea
yeah just focus on damage where because we have enough heals
for it and i can we just speed ring our rissa to walk
towards their cast oh oh yeah you have to play him further a
bit further back sure oh i'm dead as hell
playing kda i'm playing kda i'm coming back to spawn all
right well Okay, that's good.
I might just have to get like dry nanoed here.
I'm way too far.
Alright.
It'll still be decent.
I'm gonna go for the mercy.
I'll follow you.
Okay.
Connor, you'll try to follow up with me on the dive, okay?
I don't even know who you are, one.
I'm main.
Yo, Zari alone.
No personal.
Okay, I'll give it to you now.
Since we're at the right side.
There's a Zari behind us.
There's a Zari behind.
behind us actually jk i just got stunned and then rooted
seems like they like to um have one person in the back and
cassidy just on the side like i could do we have any ults
here sorry weak oh no damn okay good try good try i think
this is the hardest team anyways 100 yeah their team is
really good it's okay that was a good try I think...
So...
Play them in the final though.
I think we'll wait.
We'll probably rematch them, but we'll get like heated up
until then.
I think like definitely wise, tanks you got LOS to support,
because I'm always like not LOS with me.
I think Brigitte would have done well there actually.
She owns always behind and Brigitte's good at taking care of
people on the bat.
flanking flankers or is it yeah i mean muzu is pretty good
too if you see their muzuki like flank us left you can chain
him and he's stuck there like you you cannot move or tp back
to his start like we have to be wary because sleepy was like
really running our back line i didn't oh yeah miss he was
muzuki right he was the muzu and he was like constantly
shifting behind us and yeah that's just like his like his
play style too because he would do that in the past the
shion but i couldn't kill her or i had like no follow-ups i
think yeah i think like yeah someone has to be with yuzu and
okay for it when we could try to to just to see since this
is just this is just like round robin right yeah no this is
yeah we could just experiment yeah well i don't think we
could that's the problem it's it's so tough it's so tough
because there's nothing really to go on and if you go on
something they just bubble it that's the problem is like i
mean we could in hindsight so what did you say you play
again reaper i did bastion okay wait should we leave this
lobby i i yeah i left okay this is gonna be a hot take i
literally think that game was way harder because it was
ilios it's okay guys hear me out i kept my pda i i I just
never play well on it.
So it's like, it's like, that was just an unlucky first
round.
I was the best player because my KDA was the highest, just
was the lowest slash highest.
We didn't want to win that because it's round robin.
It's better to get them in a false sense of security.
I will say I didn't leave my team to die because there was
no reason.
If I was alive, it would not benefit in any way.
It would not.
Oh, right.
Sorry, one.
Sorry, I didn't realize that we're trying.
Yeah, no, we were just taking it easy on them, letting them
feel like they're the best team in the tournament, right?
yeah guys technically if i died with my team it wouldn't
contribute to anything i also need to make my waiting room
tweet about you right now yeah he's thinking like but i
brought up the two two two because shoda really wanted it's
the next game he'll be really pushing for it and i was just
like it's brown robin it's fine we should be we should
experiment he's onto something yeah and that's true like we
should try out different comps and see what works best for
us yeah everyone likes an underdog storage you know i mean
happy galmore dodgeball exactly i denied them the alt chart
exactly because then everybody's like oh let's chalk it up
team war is bad like did you see what just happened and then
next team they're gonna be blindsided it's gonna be like
whoa this is not the same team that just got oh yeah they're
like ggs i think like the team balancing i'm excited for
this game okay we're playing against team frog the place now
because uh four people had to drop out this one so people
they were all like just grab it like just grab someone that
is around the same you know like it's so good it's so good
you could be like more of three different teams had to be
done they had like last like four people had to drop out
yesterday so three teams had to get revenge live if i peaked
even the crumb so like i feel like i would have lived better
on brigita or like or like moira or something okay sure i
just think brick is brig meta still i yeah that's the thing
i i know brig they work is basically the better brig now
yeah like brig is like a throw pick now so she she got like
mega nerfed from what i was told yeah unless it's like a
really vertical map and you're just whip shotting their dive
tanks off high ground but like that's yeah if they're on
dive tank then like it makes more sense to yeah because
they're on arissa and zarya it's like they're just gonna
walk over you i just remember brig being a throw pick
because i had a brick player like the main thing i'd say the
main takeaway from last game is be a little more wary about
what i was just like if you see he's like hard planking
behind if you hit a chain we gotta bring around and i
believe in you and then i was like you just died you can't
get away with that okay i think that's how i know No
pressure.
It's all new.
No pressure.
No pressure at all.
All of us.
I feel all the pressure.
Another thing, Connor, you and I, so from what I saw in the
captain's chat, their mercy is like brand, brand new.
So you and I have to apply more pressure, I would say, on
their mercy.
Well, there's Taiwan.
We can literally like I think Taiwan only played Ryan,
right?
So we could just bully the Ryan.
wait is he gonna listen if he wants to go rhyme I'm happy to
do a rhyme but I'm I will happily just tell him the 1v1 me
on side on the side of the map oh he'll take it he'll take
it he will take it yeah he will take it I don't actually I
don't know if his team will yell at him and then he won't
take it he might lock in he might lock in I feel like I did
not have that much impact last game suggestion for this team
you said you play ryan right i play ryan zarya winston diva
i think ryan could be good into that because it get mega
buffed well it's just like it's just like if he's like mercy
pocketed cast and we're just walking forward with shield
like he can't really do much i'm letting him talk so i can
make my waiting room through like seeing the last listen do
you give me the green light captain okay and i will i will
do that you know that might be a comp where Ryan's good
because I will say counter Zarya.
Because I'm going to get destroyed in both tournaments.
I definitely feel like although Arisa might be the better
pick in the comp, I would have more impact on a character
that is on paper worse.
Because I'm more comfortable with them.
Arisa's nice.
But it's up to you, though.
If you want me to stick with Arisa because you see things
that I don't see, I trust you.
Okay.
And next time I will switch off Shion if they're running
like because I can't do much against that.
Because I was thinking I could also deal with the...
Mercy as Zaria too.
I've adjusted...
To a certain degree.
Like I can...
Grab is huge.
Grab is huge too.
Just like game winning.
Let's just go.
Yeah.
New challenges.
See when we run...
See when we run three supports.
Yeah.
But the two tanks we're running is hazard.
And I also can't really dive in.
So I'm kind of playing from a dive in.
distance I don't feel like I'm doing much damage should be
able to though we have like Mizuki and Anna you should he is
he is the LOS me because um uh when you were playing when
we're I guess it's because of the EOS map but you were like
in the corner at the side at the bottom and I was yeah yeah
you felt like when you're like using LOS me and then I can
heal you guys that's i think this map's ours it's more flat
like our team comp is better on flat brawly maps like surah
vaso which we're about to play um they were taking i am
ready to get i am ready to get destroyed but i'll i think we
ban cast from here on out i'm not even trolling when i say
that i've bashed my head cast is the best dps in the game i
i think that's just our guaranteed ban on and bash my head
are you down and he also hard counters shion which is what
i'm trying to play so for so long it's time there you go
that's how i'm gonna oh my gosh i'm gonna bring you so slow
right now that's how i'm gonna yes exactly do the waiting
yeah shion's really really strong right now there was just
not like many openings okay i'm gonna ban cast i think we
just ban cast every game tournament of the day okay is whose
frog are gonna play lucio or jetpack for sure he's on lucio
um so my guess is they're going to be on reinhart i believe
this is going to be a ryan lucio brawl comp okay um we got
this this is a game i swear on everything destroyed in two
games in one day let's go i'm done okay also my cat's life
we just to raise the stakes exactly I still stay on uh I
still am Moira right for this one uh yeah yeah I'd say so I
I will say though it considering um me and Ana is pretty
strong heals I feel like you just focus on DPSing and like
okay just pure DPS just throw like damage or if you really
feel like we need healing then you can heal but I feel like
okay yeah I think I think the biggest issue is you were
frontlining a little too much as mora um you just focus on
just putting your hand at the right click and then throwing
damage or about because like your right click also destroys
ryan shield so you can contribute and destroy net she's also
really good at like if she on like if warren wants to go on
their back line like mora's also really good at following up
on that because she has like she has really good like she's
really slippery okay right what i would do is mainly damage
boost and so i found that I mainly throw damage orbs in my
tier.
Instead of heal orbs.
And I think if you eat heal orbs, if you people are crit,
then you throw heal.
Because people who are so much better than me.
But in the early to mid fight, it should just be damage
orbs.
Like right off the bat, I think me learning a new character
within two weeks was sort of like, sort of like an issue.
Let's get a team.
I feel like the thing is, I definitely was not the one to
practice the most.
The Viper player practice.
So they are all very well away.
Do you want to do you want to run?
uh they're gonna be on ryan hearts you tell me i think i
think ory i think ory all right just bother him just shoot
him break his shield but like everyone else everyone else
has been playing their main for like okay so maybe a year or
two honor on the lucy i was like i'm gonna buy in two weeks
i've ever seen my life if we're like if we're like 99 with
one i would be the thing is i can't be the water boy
might also get absolutely destroyed.
I just don't have 12 hours a day of fighting.
I would actually go crazy.
I went crazy last night.
I would absolutely go fucking crazy.
I'm not that strong enough.
Let's game.
Come on, dude.
I'm actually stoned.
I feel like we needed that.
Am I following?
Oh, yeah, we're going this way.
follow me don't Winston no I'm with you guys motorbikes okay
is he spy checking okay Winston was right here Reinhard
Winston right side okay we have a really good comp against
them group up and let's just huddle right here come to me
come to me I'm with you yeah I'm with you okay we can
pressure him break bubble break bubble I'm going in I'm
going in wait on run no need okay me rotate left side rotate
to me we're here a little more open
Winston half HP right okay we're gonna walk through Arissa
once you're healed up okay ready guys three two one let's
start moving Oh on Ryan I need help I need help oh we're
even we're even at the moment where do you want Ryan I'm
with you I'm with you bro Ryan super low uh Winston just
walked up to me good is just Lucy on your one went and ate
my butt Okay, the Winston just walked forward.
Winston and Unrun.
Who did we get from that?
The way I just literally can't see when Winston attacks.
Yeah, you put down the bubble.
I'm just gonna save Nade for Diveson.
That's a good idea.
Big anti on the Winston just kills him.
They don't have any cleanses, so keep that in mind.
Okay, let's walk up right side.
Ryan's here.
We should feel confident walking forward, okay?
So don't be too worried about heals.
leaving our supports.
I got one.
Good pick, good pick, good pick.
I'm going in.
Everybody group up.
Huge anti.
Ryan's purple.
Winston purple.
Hear that.
Got she on.
You're in bubble.
You're in bubble, Larissa.
I tried.
I said nano.
It's not over.
We might be able to nano.
I don't think I can only nano hazard.
Yeah, it's already lost.
Okay, let's group up to the right side.
I'm still alive here on the point.
I need an answer to Winston when he goes on.
I think maybe we can't protect you.
Get off of triple support.
Yeah, we'll use coalescence first.
We're going to use coalescence when we get it on Moira ult.
And then we'll go Reaper after, okay, bro?
Okay.
We'll try that.
I have all.
All right, can you nano me soon?
Yeah, just call for it.
I'll come and play with you.
They're playing slow because they realize we have nano.
Hey, you're gonna hit me now
Handside Oh my god, I got I got I got but oh my god.
I tried to kill and she killed me.
We get to win.
We get to win Lucy a week.
Lucy a week on me.
Winston is all
Just Winston try to apply pressure make sure he doesn't kill
your Moira You can go Reaper now Shoto.
Yeah, I'm going Reaper.
No supports No supports, you have no supports, just careful.
Or Mitsu's almost back.
All right, now you have a support.
Hazard, you're by yourself, Hazard, you're LS.
Fuck.
Winston's one, Winston one HP, Winston absolute.
Uphold, good job.
That's three, that's three.
I have to reload, I have to reload.
I need heals, main.
Wait.
On run.
On run, on run.
I'm sorry, I had to leave you.
I feel so much more better on this.
Let's go.
On-run, on-run.
I have to reload.
I need help with on-run.
Oh, she's so quick.
She's so quick.
I have to reload.
You got it.
Take your time.
Get healed up.
I'm hurt.
Yeah, you only have one support right now.
We still need to flip points.
So break bubble.
Really?
Huge flip.
Now we just played to our core.
We're going to get ready to nano Xi on this way.
Wait for my bike if possible.
Just call for it.
Winston's just gonna jump on me.
Keep shooting Rineshield.
Oh, as well.
She owns?
Hey, hit me, hit me, hit me.
I got you.
Rineshield's broken almost.
You hazard your, you are LOS, you are LOS.
You motherfucker.
I got one, I got one.
Nice.
Come on, Rines, Rines, Rines, Rines.
You might need an alt here.
Winston purple.
Good picks.
Lucio in.
Don't let him flip.
They'll probably get TK here.
Have to reload at all.
Oh, good try, good try, good try.
All set.
Can anyone touch?
I don't think so.
No, I'm not close.
No, I won't touch then.
It's fine, I'm rotating.
Yeah, I'll just retreat.
Motherfucking frogger.
And we have Vizuol.
This is why Vizuol, yeah.
I haven't, I can build it all in this fight.
Yeah, they use a lot.
We can use it more like...
Oh, Reaper, you okay over there?
They have B and they should have...
I think they try to cut me off there.
I got him.
So what we're going to do is we're going to Mizuki alt on
point when it unlocks.
And we all just playing it.
And they should have Winston alt again.
Okay.
Cool.
Your LOS, me, me.
Okay.
Play together.
Should I get shield perk now?
When do I, when do you want me to alt?
Oh, I need a bit of help left, right side.
Oh, Winston's on me.
I got you.
Good help, good help.
I can't heal all of that.
You have three people on you.
Oh, nice.
Good pick.
I'm on point.
I got pushed off.
This might be calling for reset.
This is full reset here.
I have a little...
Damn, they got so many...
Warren, you want me getting Javelin or...
Or shield?
I would say Javelin.
Hey, you have Nano.
Evel.
Okay, I'm ready.
You can hit me in three, two, one.
Hit me.
Okay.
I'm on I'm on right hard behind And side nice we should push
up no more else no more else push up push up Go to point go
to point go to point go to point there's an on-run on point
on me.
It's just One good cap good cap.
I could take more 1v1s if you throw me There's four of mine.
Yeah, they have one.
They have support Yo, Ryan's here.
I'm just getting right shield.
I'm just getting right shield I can't honor a minus
Remember, does this play around our heals?
They're gonna push for that.
Yeah, since we're down.
We have Musiwalt still.
We're good.
And I'm almost at my ult.
Yeah, they have both supports.
I'm doing- I'm applying so much pressure.
Oh my god.
I'm coming back.
Are you able to get out?
More- Oh!
Okay, we have Musiwalt.
Nice ult.
I got pinned.
I got pinned out of the ult.
No, uh, on-run could I?
Holy...
Oh, yeah.
On-run.
unrun moment yeah i don't think we can get you here oh good
try good try good try ggs that was better though that felt
better that felt better generally i think i should be on zps
yeah 2t2 seems a bit better sure i think it's just because
like i'm able to disrupt a bit more yeah true true oh guys
my food is here i'll be right back oh you won't oh my god
dude i'll be right back off with four times daughter just
getting bullied bro but i came for the king and i fucking
messed that
was awesome not too shabby so does this uh was this round
robins right yeah none of those really matters just to get a
feel for it and then when the bracket starts that's when we
really have to use all of our collective knowledge to win
exactly okay wait so this is not counting then or what what
is what is no it's just for seating it's just for seating
yeah we're getting seated if we come last place we'll likely
play against the best uh team in round robin which is if i
had to guess applies team again so we need to try to take a
win if we take one or two wins here moving forward we will
avoid the apply team until later in the tournament which is
ideal oh okay interesting i do think we played much better
there though that was good that was i would say main things
i'm not doing well right now on muzu you can go for moira if
you feel like it'll help then then yeah if you think you can
like live longer give better burst deals on our tank like
whatever yeah run it that could be something at least i do
think like at least in round robin if it's not if we're just
getting seated i feel like it's better to try out what like
different options rather than like the actual yeah the only
i will say the only downside of switching off music once
again is a character like on ron or winston are just going
to be able to do more that's the only downside yeah i don't
feel like i was i'm using my stuff son winston or on ron so
it might just be better honestly than moira in that case if
we if we feel like we're not hitting it and you just want to
apply pressure on her oh i'm gonna say on ron it's not a bad
option In the end, I did my job.
I don't think me having more sleep would change anything
regarding my performance.
I have a question.
What about in what situation do you think Bastion would be
better than Reaper?
So interestingly, I actually think Bastion would have been
better there just for blowing up Tyler 1's shield because
the thing is, he was walking around doing nothing.
I don't know if you guys saw, but he was just holding shield
the whole game.
I was considering Bastion swap there.
I felt like I did everything I could in the situation I was
in.
I got my aunties.
I mean, Reaper helps deal with...
I got my auntie.
Unless I fucking kill everyone.
Like, he has Ana.
You can clear or cleanse yourself from a burn.
I have to say.
And if Enron burns you, you can like go into that form and
cleanse it so you're no longer burning to death.
Enron's just really annoying.
I actually cannot believe.
Who is Eido?
Who was that?
How the fuck did you...
That's not an easy hero to play.
I'm just shocked.
That's like a non-overwatch player.
They were owning.
Oh.
They're...
They're an FPS player.
They're an FPS gamer.
I think they're like a top 500 and something.
I don't know.
So I think it's just easy for them to transfer knowledge.
No,
I'm just saying.
I did my job.
Here's the good news.
You guys want the good news?
Is he top 500 deadlock?
Yes.
The good news is we just had to play against, in my opinion,
the top two teams in the tournament.
which oh yeah apply steam and fraud or steam respect
apparently their onron is top 500 and deadlock or something
so yeah to be very honest with you onron's a character that
you need a lot of time on to be playing like that i think
they just play overwatch off stream i i think for sure they
got it they had a secret weapon also deadlock's pretty new
no it's not it's been around for at least a year now okay
that's new in overwatch terms an old that's okay i was gonna
say it has aim in it that's funny that's funny because like
it's very plausible this person just played overwatch before
deadlock since it was only a year old that game like it's
cute and teams are not balanced i think like this game this
tournament is more for fun which one's the bouncing was done
via like friends like oh they know this person form so maybe
they'll be more comfortable playing with each other is the
self heal better or like the exploding um was it maneuver
wait let me let me uh double check i'm gonna go to the
practice range and help a bit um yeah like the overwatch in
general has become very perk heavy um let me go find out and
it's like we have the weakest they just made some changes to
his perks so i would say when he announced it but we said
our team has the weakest front i would do configuration
reload for your minor perk which is the reduce the cooldown
of the grenade by four seconds when changing configurations
so in recon out of recon mode just because of balancing um
and then this one is really is a really good dps player this
one's tough generally
i i personally think self-repair is better because if you're
low then you don't need to depend on doki and use you as
much you can just like take a little bit more off angles
exactly for dps stuff yeah i like self-heal better okay i
feel like with my play style i would like self-heal as well
you think you in the practice that you did have the bastion
felt better than every other team both not every team but
like the teams we faced all have really the benefit of
bastion it's it's a little more longer range than reaper
like decent players too if we're in the early fight let's
say apply with a mercy pocket you can actually shoot it i
feel like i was able to apply a lot players that play
recently um like at least one one keep me safe too so i was
longer range and yeah i felt safer but i think it's just i
want to i think in those situations i gotta know like i'm
because like yeah okay okay okay yeah the main i would say
the main thing is make sure you save your turf form for when
we're actually on the objective or in a team fight if you
use it back up with flash and loses a ton of value i need to
eat food like i would say if you see tyler one in our face
and i'd use turf form blow up his i just want to play
there's no way he's
my ultimate seems easy to dodge yeah ult's not great i'm
doing my job they just nerfed it that's why they literally
changed he had a minor perk where he got like 600 or 800 hp
just off using the ult i'm doing my part defensively rather
than offensively so it'd be like if you're about to die
people just like press q get like all their hp back get hope
from their supports and then just like back to playing the
game almost like a waste all okay so don't like take too
much time in as all so you're going oh i was gonna say do
you want me to try kiriko or do you want to stick with anna
uh i think you stick with anna we were winning some fights
with nano and i was getting like easy like one shots on
certain people but once again i i i don't want you guys
think i'm lying when i saw all the rosters those two rosters
were easily the strongest i feel like that's gonna be a good
thing um wait who are we playing next
I swear I swear team among I thought was the strongest and
then you said team so Aspen's the strongest no no no team
Aspen's not the strongest team apply apply and fire the
strongest just because of their the players they have like
overall like the non overwatch players that they have are
generally like actual overwatch players like I know for sure
like no one can just pick up on Ron and do what he was doing
on on run but that he did have a good he did have flats
diving with him though which has contributed a lot um okay
yuzu i will say emong being the best player on this next
team the chains might be very useful what what does he play
diva he plays diva so if he's like no i i agree it's when i
saw when i saw i think this is a zaria it's for round
robbing so it doesn't matter not and still eliminated yeah
this is gonna be like you are even if we are even if we
don't make it to the finals of connor that means i have
enough time to chill out before my next tournament so i have
enough time to disassociate before i get destroyed again
before i also get destroyed again
uh yeah i don't want to be the guy because i think emong is
one of the captains that said he doesn't lose to practice
mine just to lose again yeah the back-to-back beatings this
is abuse i don't feel too i don't really i'm not gonna lie
i'm just playing to play um just because like i do enjoy
playing overwatch and like i don't really care what
placement plays may and some um i don't care what placement
we get in the end because I'm just biving to it's free money
and also I get to play Overwatch.
So if I do get destroyed in both tournaments sometimes
that's how the world works is sometimes sometimes that's how
life is.
Someone wants you to add them on top of it.
Yeah, I'm asking for it.
I'm still, I'm doing it for the, I'm getting destroyed for
the love of the game.
I'm doing my part.
Maybe not in the Street Fighter.
I might not be doing my part in Street Fighter.
But I have been fucking practicing every day.
Like some people here have not been practicing every day.
But they're still better than me.
That's the first part.
I'm bashing my head.
I feel like I...
And then they just are naturally good at fighting games.
Like they don't need to practice every day.
They're me in Overwatch.
I literally can just autopilot Overwatch.
like i have to bash my head against the wall just to be a
fraction of their level yeah i think we i think banning i
know i just want to have a little bit more fun worst part is
the amount of hours i spent in stream fighting for this
tournament just to know like even though i know i'm gonna
get my ass kicked whatever but i'm just trying to make it
look like a decent fight talent versus hard work classic
stuff i just i just wanted to look like at least i'm trying
like i didn't have acid you know i'm like at least i'm
trying my best to contribute to the tournament i didn't like
i'm not phoning it in
Like, I was there.
Yeah, it's not to lose.
I, oh my gosh, I'm playing with all of that.
I still end up losing miserably.
I'll be so sad.
Oh, bro.
No, I will not be sad.
I know what I was getting into.
I will not be sad.
You're right.
Connor, what do you think, like, you need help with in these
fights?
Everything.
I definitely LOS, LOSing me.
Yeah, LOS is the number one thing I've been saying.
That was my biggest thing I saw.
Right, okay.
I'd be missing on our team.
I'd probably say when you so speak in code, like, LOSing, I
don't have a clue.
with line of sight line of sight so just you you whenever i
say los you're just not in my sight when i'm healing so
you're like behind something or you're you're playing like
too far off from the team because i can't out position
myself just to heal you it'll help having zarya it'll really
help having zarya because he's not going to be instantly
crit on engage since he'll have it hopefully a bubble okay
yeah i think like when i saw you on hazard uh sometimes you
jump in when you're critical so so that's why it's like a
little harder especially when you're los oh they banned ash
yeah wait a second yeah i do the opposite when i when i get
really low in health that's when i dive if yeah so it's okay
guys i did my part i did my part kept my kda secured i might
have the best kda in my team i say is everyone's dying and
i'm I know, I'm just baiting them.
Oh, you love his...
That's the Hazard's voice actor.
You know what was so...
It was sad to see...
When Teams came out, and then Hazard got nerfed in the
patch.
Because, like, that's...
You know, because Connor is the voice actor of Hazard, so he
plays Hazard.
And then Teams came out.
And then the day after...
The patch notes came out.
You can't let Hercubus to the other team.
No, that's good.
And then hasn't gotten nerfed.
I mean, Tracer.
I mean, yeah.
He's like, he's a hazard one trick because the thing he
literally plays.
It's like, you know, it's like Sayu.
But I do think Tracer is a little more annoying for our back
line.
Yeah, we keep playing against like these flankers and stuff.
Wait, wait, why can't these guys just?
I wish we could play more front to back Overwatch.
I have to have a lot of flankers.
Nico or Doki Bird will really be helpful because like the
last two games it was really hard to protect Doki like they
kept yeah they just hard dove me yeah okay you know if we
play against that Frogger roster again Kiri probably is best
yeah cleanse anything she does and that she's out of
position I think so too they all they do is just dive me I
at now I am tied them but like I just
if they're on sigma either way either way i want us to take
our time build up charge on daria and that's just going to
give us like a third dps on our team okay but yeah like when
i was like it was anna against that like i anti them but i
just like i don't know like they you know i just need follow
up or something but i think here is a better option yeah all
right here you go i'm getting a little worried about the
thought of Bastion Reaper into Diva, just because you're
hard countered, but you're still a problem.
Like, you're enough of a problem where she's going to be too
busy defense matricing instead of killing her.
Yeah, I was going to say she's just eating.
Like, she just has spent her entire time eating.
Exactly.
I'll up show it up a bit more.
I don't know.
I guess your goal in this game is just going to be like, how
do I force Emong to spend more time using defense matrix on
Diva, like, eating than damaging?
so bastion is better for this yeah i would say bastion just
keep pressure so she always has to use her defense they
remember they used to fake your essence this is a for fun
overwatch tournament i don't know what i was getting into no
matter what whatever placement i get in this tournament even
if it's last place you're saying they're both it's gonna be
more money i don't know for in this tournament then the
street fighter tournament I know what I was getting into
well maybe the guy with the Reinhardt profile picture oh
yeah he plays Reinhardt where it's where we get serious yeah
street fighters where we get serious here
so we're ready to go let's do it okay main goal apply
pressure on Reinhardt okay here we go uh diva defense matrix
forced her to use all of it.
Remember that they cannot see what we're running this time.
Nope, they can't.
I just always pick a random hero to start.
I just don't pick.
Like, wait.
No, they can't see anymore.
You're good to pick your mains.
Alright.
Here we go.
I do think the basket is the extra amount of cheese that we
needed.
This is good.
I like 2-2-2.
I think it's time where Where did this guy get it?
Where is it?
Is this one?
No?
I think it's time.
This is how I feel right now.
I'm less tired.
I got my coffee in.
Unless I got my coffee.
This is how I feel now playing this game.
Is this a capture of the point map?
Yeah, it's King of the Hill.
King of the Hill.
Follow me up.
No, this is good.
This is good.
I like so much.
It's tough time.
Watch the Sombra, okay?
Make sure you guys are peeling for each other.
We didn't ban Sombra?
Wait, what do we...
No, I ban May.
Okay, they're on Sigma.
So listen, we cannot walk into them.
Come left.
Come here.
Oh, no.
He's on.
He's on Sombra.
Okay, let's walk through.
Wait, wait.
Save your charge.
Take your charge.
Yep.
Reloading.
Sigma shield low Sigma no shield main no hands either it's a
good time to engage good walk yeah I broke you I'm bringing
shield creeper low creeper low oh wait all right charge down
I'm low I'm weak I'm weak he got me though I need heals
Thanks.
You're up one.
You're up two.
You only have more heals though, so be careful.
Oh, no.
I'm coming over.
I'm all.
You should use it.
I'm sleeping.
Can we shoot Sig?
I'm just using.
I'm sleeping and low.
We're winning this.
We got this.
Rhinard one.
Rhinard one is BAPCM.
And I'm dead.
Oh, yeah.
There's no more else.
No more else.
We win this.
There's a Shion.
Shion.
Tracer one.
Huge.
Good.
Huge breakout fight.
I feel very comfortable in Moira actually.
I have nano soon.
Sure.
Let's um, let's play like here.
Everybody group up.
I'm gonna be here.
Yeah.
They don't have really any.
Oh, they're on tracer now.
Yep.
Yeah.
They're gonna have Chiano.
Maybe.
I have an ult.
Like what do I use this thing?
Oh, you can use it now if you want.
They don't have a projected bubble.
I'm just.
I'm all too.
I slept I slept with tracer.
Oh, I think I've been thinking.
Oh, no, I'm oh, no, no.
Yeah, I slept No, that's fine.
Just die.
Go next.
So what did they use that was just shatter shatter?
Shatter.
Yeah, I used nano down you earlier.
Okay.
Emong switch to Zarya.
I wanted to Wanted to force something?
Imagine Emong switching Yo, um, they have tracer bomb and
grab.
Oh, no, they swap.
Should have not fall um we're gonna just build up our grab
and then we're gonna combo okay abdullah i'm gonna save my
hope for you you heals right i slept tracer i can oh my god
oh my god oh my god tracer should die dead i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead we can still turn this oh never mind oh my god i
got grab off uh we have one last play here easy i got grab
for this okay we have co-lessons on the way back we have to
go go go 20 seconds got time i i could touch from underneath
you guys just play slow play smart okay uh we could play
okay they're made one fuck oh no yamong knows yamong
realizes we need to touch though i can touch i can touch i
go with zara go with zara i'm with you i'm with
you i'm ready for your ult can you touch uh there is a shion
behind us planking behind us huge wait where where hang it
i'm point on point now i'm playing on point on point yeah i
just got flanked nice connor and shoto we're gonna look to
combo your guys's ultimates okay so connor's gonna use ult
slam them down and you're gonna land your artillery on top
of the the stuck targets okay just let me know you just get
your back one level late i'm in 94 percent yeah you're gonna
build it for sure they're just gonna flank and find me i'm
just gonna be careful i'm with poke poke poke play for you
just tell me when to out right and we might have to look for
something i've got it now yeah i'm dead one i mean i slept
oh god holy shit no stress that was pretty decent that's
pretty good i mean yeah not bad too not i feel like this is
i feel like we're more put together like this right now
definitely yeah I do like my Mora right now.
I don't like...
I feel like I'm doing something at least.
Yeah, I'm just...
We're cooking.
I might play next to the team just because the Ruben's just
looking hard, looking for me.
Okay.
I get my sleep, but then something will kill me.
One thing we have to care, one thing we have to keep in
mind, all right, Zarya only gets one personal bubble and one
projected bubble, aka onto another teammate.
So I'm going to try to do my best to call out when she has
no bubbles, Shoto, and then you use your form, and we just
blow them up, okay?
Is Aria specifically?
Okay.
Uh, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, I'll just keep track.
So, like, if they bubble their Reinhardt, we do not shoot
bubble, and then when it's gone, we shoot in your form.
Heard.
We're going top right.
That's okay.
We can play point.
Play with me.
Hello, Tom.
Oh, shit.
Come behind, behind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
my sleep more than one hp i have the reload i need a bit of
heels i'm coming back for you we're even at the moment by
the way they lost the support shoto do you have your uh oh
wait what's going on behind us yeah i don't know what's
going on back here i killed them and they killed me she on
dead she on dead uh we're even technically we just don't
have it they're
Still even.
Yep.
Ryan half.
They use Bubble, okay?
I'm on him right now.
Ryan one!
Oh, we're even, we're even, we're even.
I'm reloading.
Oh, we're down one.
I have ult, though.
Need a bit of heals as well.
Connor needs heals.
I could go on there.
I slept, I slept, I slept, I slept, I slept.
Oh.
She's one, she's one, she's one.
Absolute on point if you see her.
I have to reload.
okay can you all live soon oh that's not this fight yeah oh
oh there's a backup oh shit they're all in here they're all
in here okay we can we can coalesce i'd say we just nano
yeah i should say okay sure let's try to go top right let's
take a different angle everybody come to me they're that
choke and we're struggling.
Someone's on the right on me here.
Okay, everyone's been bunched up, so I might nano the wrong
person.
Okay, I'm splitting off here.
Are you ready to hit me?
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
Oh, I turned around too.
Try to get you a bubble.
It's just you and...
Oh.
Wait, it's...
I don't even know if it's even or not.
I don't know how many people died.
Yeah, it's even.
I can touch.
I got it yeah team kill they their teams coming back now too
they're coming back to you should be able to flip for free
all right we have cold right great job so this fight we need
to build up our hazel and then we call lessons walk forward
after we use it so just keep farming a connor they're gonna
have grabs soon personal bubble gone i can't no los for
heals i'm playing main Soldier week, soldier week in a zone.
Mathicle here.
Soldier absolute, absolute.
Nice.
Next target, please.
They're gonna, they have Zara.
They have, oh, Shion's on me.
Yeah, they nano Shion.
Oh my goodness.
More absolute, more one, dead.
You're, yeah.
No.
Good try.
God damn.
I mean, it's best we did.
We did, we did our best, guys.
We're improving.
For sure.
Rapidly improving, I'd say.
Is there like another team that we're going up against?
Yes, Aspen's team.
I think that's the last team.
Oh, no, sorry.
Two more teams.
Oh, two teams.
Oh, never met.
Those new characters looked insane.
Yeah, it's nuts.
Yeah, we just didn't have a shield for it, too.
So we just have to be aware whenever they had shatter.
I didn't call it the shatter because I've...
I like that we're getting the hang of it.
We're starting to have a little bit more...
every time every time it was like why don't i just go
reinhart every time i wanted to like nano i get shattered no
attack just you like so i couldn't i couldn't like focus up
on like figure out if they had shattered or not reinhart did
get buffed yeah i mean walking forward with shield is kind
of what tyler one is doing we just say ryan i think reinhart
is really strong ryan would be a really good alt battery too
right right yeah okay let's do it let's do it connor you
want to switch it up try something new might as well in
these last two games in it okay let's give it a go if
someone else wants to play tank i would go support if
anybody else is like i could definitely put tank yeah i
think we stick it let's try it out let's try to play ryan do
you know what perks you need on reinhart no it's okay guys i
did my part i mean i would just genuinely be walking with my
shield Yeah, but he has a perk that helps them with the
shield.
We're like, we were like, if we lose, it's your fault.
Or no, no, that's what it is.
I'm joking.
So he has a perk that's called Crusaders Resolve as his
minor perk.
While using Barrier Field, your passive health regen
triggers 75% sooner.
So you'll start healing yourself 75% faster after you use
your shield.
Okay, I'll probably ask you in game again, like, okay, what
was that thing again?
It's the, it's the minor perk that looks like a shield with
a heal icon.
what is it called crusaders resolve lowest ring players me
well um abdullah i'm already getting invited to the next
team but he hasn't played in a while rolled right now uh
that's that's good there's more so it's more so of like uh
everyone everyone's just trying to think about it trying to
like remember i'll play the game i'm gonna do i'm not
playing tank i should say like if we need player we need to
switch things up I could try okay these guys are on cast I
don't care if he's a cast I'm like if we need to switch
things up maybe I can swap but I'm not going to I only said
it to be polite y
'all might be right back okay all right I'm just associating
give me a sec Why is my captain not inviting me?
Oh, there it is.
Yay.
I'm so polite.
I can't wait to also get beat up in Street Fighter.
And God, God, free money!
And I get to play Overwatch.
I get to play Overwatch and get free money at the same time.
I do that for free!
I play Overwatch for free!
right think of it this way guys i play overwatch off stream
for free for nobody but now i get to play overwatch and get
free money guys the more you say that the more here i'm just
trying to send my son like i try not to be sad at street
fighter because you guys have no idea how many hours i put
into that game for for my tier i was like i don't want to
get i was like i'm trying not to like break down jersey
fight it when it does happen usually are you like an anime
oh oh what do you say oh what supports you usually play oh
me uh i play any i play everything but bap in wuyang oh so
it's like whatever the team needs uh-huh do you do you feel
like what do you feel like on on honor currently i think
like okay are we are winning fights because of the nano
basically and then i i got all i've hit every all my not
every sleep but like i hit all the sleeps on my flankers
during the last game it was more so like it was just you
know are you are you struggling to like do you do you need
me to like try to be near you more i think it's more more so
like we just gotta be aware I I can I can try to be more
aware the flankers when I first noticed we're getting
flanked I started like calling it up them out um yeah I
tried to I tried to be more mindful on the flankers yeah
it's a little they would send like two flankers behind us so
I think maybe if they have two flankers then you can play
next to me but they don't have any flankers you can you can
just be free because i can just heal from far but they had
like two flankers there
yeah oh yeah oh yeah and also when i sleep someone don't
wake them up so we can do a countdown together because i
think i slept i remember i slept i accidentally woke up yeah
yeah yeah yeah so if i sleep someone and you're next to me
we'll just do a three two one together okay and then because
if we three two one they'll just insta die if they're like a
little baby i was just brain off moira holding r or holding
right yeah or like when the orb is flying you can't do
anything about it
do you think like do you think we might be overestimating
anna's like nano boost though like even though we win fights
like the the gen like we won't have nano like all the time
so like to be able to live and hold the point as long as
possible rather than just win fights with a nano you know we
try i mean i tried kiri or i feel like she's pretty good
yeah we could try kiri it's just suzu yeah i i do like the
nanos and like the winning fights with nanos but i think our
problem currently with our team is like we're not we're not
uh holding points like we can win fights but we can't hold
the point it's just positioning like our comp is fine our
comp is fine we're just like we're just like not positioning
properly around the ultimates that they do have so i'll try
to do a better job at like calling hey they have shatter and
then we can rotate around the map differently based on that
because if we just like because we don't have a shield tank
too for some of these ults so no now we do now we do well
actually well now that we have ryan i think anna will be
really good for the that's true yeah because it was just
like partially it was positioning and then partially i feel
like i feel like it could also be like character we just
like if we're just really bad at positioning i feel like
characters that have high survivability could be an option
you know yeah that was the original goal with arissa hazard
was just like block slop just like win a fight and then just
like have damage reduction abilities but i do think the
shield presence is going to make it harder to shoot at you
guys past our hazard like i think something the other teams
that we're benefiting from like for example apply with the
mercy pocket is they were just saying all right well well we
could just shoot right past the hazard and the orissa since
they don't have that shield or defense matrix right and
that's what he was doing is he was like slowly picking off
all the squishies but okay i reckon we banned they would
just go off try mercy we could try and then damage been a
hard pocket you do what they did okay do you do you want
mercy or Anna I could go either or I can go out there too
using you feel more just whichever you're more comfortable
um I'd play more Anna but I don't think Mercy is that
difficult I mean, I mean, it depends on, I guess, like, I
think you're better at my, at the sleeps, though.
Like, you've been playing out of the whole tournament, so
you're probably, like, more warmed up on that.
The other team banned Sierra.
All right.
Oh, no.
Not my Sierra.
That I will not be playing.
Sierra banned.
What perks are good on Mercy?
Which one's the, um, it's the, it was the guard, it was the
range one, and then the, I remember they changed the flash
shield to something else.
So I'm trying to remember what the other one was.
The major perk is double flash shield.
Do we feel like we can sustain, though, with Mercy Ana?
Mercy Ana?
I think we just stayed in hard pot.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can get solo kills without Mercy pocket.
We should be good.
I do feel like the damage on Moira was pretty...
The Moro was good.
Yeah, you were building alt really, really fast.
Let's do it.
We're starting to get the hang of it.
Let's not pivot.
well this would be the last match not one more there's one
more after this I think this is the one thing we try
something new is Reinhardt here see how comfortable we are
just walking forward with shield and taking map space
because of it I forgot I was playing Reinhardt obviously
soon you were talking about soon you were talking about she
was actually good how do you feel about the Zarya bro oh
great felt great and then I just got Zarya difter because
zmon switched yeah it was going it was going so well that
emong had to switch which is a testament i i'll take that to
the grave ok yeah you make him switch he is the best tank
player in the tournament straight up so it's like if
anyone's gonna be able to switch and have an impact you
can't be saying that in front of connor no no no i think
connor is the is the zaya ryan yeah zaya ryan the classic og
season one classic give me that you were building all fast
too give me that arm wrestle give me that arm wrestle spray
oh that was classic if that's doesn't work one at some point
just tell me switch and i'll switch i think if you just like
just walk forward and know when it's low and back up and
then get it back and then go in we should never really lose
map space the thing about us and what we're struggling with
is we'll And then we immediately lose the next one.
Yeah, yeah.
I think we're relying too much on our ults.
Versus a neutral fight.
I think, like, during a neutral fight, we just get picked
off one by one.
So having right shields should help.
Yeah.
We're locking in.
So you guys are going to go out from right side here, okay?
I'm going to hold the off angle left.
You guys go right.
Okay.
Alrighty.
So get ready to 3, 2, 1, and then shift in.
okay bro yeah we're moving on hog is on our left hog's on
our left you want me to come left and attack somebody oh wow
they all wish left side out okay holy that's why we could
turn a little really i think you're time build up your
shield and let a break i can't move back i'll move back i'll
be back soon i'm here in like two seconds okay okay let's
rotate left or right okay that's Connor's right.
Yeah, follow your tank.
I'm going to off angle.
Our run is shielded off.
Our run is walled off.
Our run.
Break the wall.
Guys, one.
Go on.
Reven.
I'm on point.
They're all, let me flip.
They see nine.
I'm really low, though.
I anti-hog.
I don't have LOS.
And we just get healed up and then go back in.
So you guys.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I was just on high ground.
No, I fell.
It's not over.
I like that cold.
Look at Soge.
Oh, there's Soge above us.
Got her.
Got it.
I'm on Moira.
She's on point.
I also have a ult.
Hug no hook.
You got it.
You can swing, bro.
You can swing.
Go walk up and swing them.
You guys only have more of Hughes.
That's good.
We're coming back.
Hug low.
Hug.
Hug on a hug.
Nice hug.
Hug.
I'm chasing hog.
Yeah, I'm chasing hog.
him good good good good good anti-zari anti-zari i would
call it go cleanse look at soge on that off angle sorry one
zero one no i'm dead i'm i'm dead huge good job you want to
have more we're playing for nano okay so we take our time
build up nano we should be able to good job i'm just look at
my damage i need like 60 percent uh i'm here watch the hog
coming left i'm just getting like picked his positioning
right now is my bed okay they're walking left our rhino's
all the way right we have to rotate right shit oh can we
heal him make sure we build up all oh he's a lot of push i'm
backing up fully i can maybe touch from underneath just play
life okay everybody live everybody live where are you where
are you where are you I'm back.
I can touch.
I'm back.
I could not touch.
I can't see you.
I got you.
I can, I can alt.
I can alt you.
We lost one.
Okay.
We'll go for next.
That's fine.
I'm just following.
I'm going to chase underneath.
We can break the main walls.
We just need to break them.
We're Connor's just going to get walled off nonstop.
Yeah.
Shoto, if you save your, you should save your bastion form
for any time they wall.
I'll play a little further back.
Okay.
Can we go in with bastion form here?
Help them out.
Three, two, one.
Yeah.
that hog live now live live live okay it's not over can you
nano me yeah i got you i got you
oh my god your wall your wall your wall your wall your wall
yeah i know i know i know anti-tied anti-tied in the back we
have no tanks we might want to reset guys you can't i
slipped someone oh we flipped it our hazards almost back our
hazard your wall your wall your wall your wall excuse me are
you okay I yeah, I don't know what to do Yeah, I don't know
if the I don't know if the rain hearts working you're good,
bro.
You're good.
We're doing okay Keep it keep it honestly, you're doing
great You're gonna die even faster on has helping me build
my alt really fast.
Yeah But if you feel comfortable anything else like this I
feel like comfortability is more than anything Okay, it's
broke, it's broke, it's broke.
No slides, Oach.
Backing up.
Oh, fuck.
He's gonna back up.
No, I trolled.
Oh, you might do it.
Oh, we have another fight if we regroup.
Oh, yeah.
They might be pushing me, or are they pushing you, Zun?
Zunari is up here.
We have Nano against you, almost shattered.
I can touch.
I'm going for it.
No walls no walls I get it.
I got it.
I died for it though.
Oh, oh, oh Nice pick good job Okay, they used a lot though.
That was whole hog male OC I got a pick from that nice skill
nice skill.
I'm holding I'm holding on.
Oh, well, you're still alive How are you doing this?
Okay.
Oh my god It's right side the point.
We gotta get there first.
Okay, I have coal last from that.
Connor, if you see them use projected bubble, the ally
bubble on Zarya.
Look for a shatter.
Okay.
All right.
After the bubble.
Do you want me to just try to ult you or this or Orner?
Yeah, definitely.
That's true.
I could.
I think we look for a shatter and then nano me.
Yeah, they're gonna have to.
Okay, wait, Shoto's halting?
See what happens.
There is a more on me.
One's on me.
Yeah, Morno fade.
Can you nanomate?
Going now.
Hit me.
I got you.
Get me.
Your wall.
I got you.
They're all there.
Oh, nice.
More on the ground.
There's arius.
Good one.
I'm switching one.
Okay.
What do you want to play?
Isaac.
Okay, I have Kolas.
I can go in on this one.
Yeah, we'll have to...
Oh, Warrior is like pretty pushed up at the moment.
They're all trying to get me.
Someone is to the left.
Okay.
I just got...
Your walled, your walled!
He's dead.
He got me 40 charge though.
Okay, now.
He's on the side here.
Hey, no.
No hook hog.
It's a good time to engage.
Any reload.
Any pressure?
I need heals.
Got you.
Oh, no.
We have a wall, okay.
Your wall.
May, may, may.
You got food.
We might want to go.
And then hit me.
I got you.
Anantize somebody.
I don't know who.
I have to reload.
Oh.
I need help on point.
Hog behind.
You got this.
uh kyriko's the only one alive there's a hog too oh hog is
alive too okay maybe a big anti oh okay i know go on up go
on up it's fine he's one he's he's low we can use him as alt
battery
where which area are they coming from here or here uh over
here main my ping on my ping they should have whole hog okay
we don't have we use graph first and then we alt it oh okay
just let me know out here abdullah looked at three two one
it so he knows when to use all okay we could just win with
this no doubt okay they're walking right get ready to grab
before they two one two one okay two people in it one of
them one of them i'm with it it's not over it's not over
it's just tanks Yeah.
Oh my god.
Hogs low.
Sorry low.
Yes.
Let's go team.
Nice.
Good dog.
I need to build off here.
I'm 83.
They don't recontest.
So just trying.
Oh yeah.
We're looking for a picture.
Yeah.
So chaff.
Okay.
So it's in front of us the point.
So follow me.
Yep, I'm with you.
Yeah, the right side?
Yep.
Hogs right here.
Be careful.
He's close.
I need.
Party mate.
No!
You're walk.
You're good.
I'm trying.
Oh, you were in the soldier thing.
I vote though.
You only have me as heal.
So low.
Please play slower.
I'm a little low inside.
I have to reload.
I got bubble and two, Warren.
On the way.
Please don't take too much damage.
Oh, they're just gonna hard push them back up.
Okay, no problem.
I can't keep you up.
Everybody out, everybody out.
Don't let them get any more kills.
We're gonna have our Nano-Shion combo here.
Connor, save your alt.
We need it.
We just gotta, like, shoot the wall.
That's our biggest problem.
Shoot the wall.
You're all just call for it.
Tell me when you want it, weren't.
We're going to save your alt.
I'm going to call for nano once I get another bike.
Okay.
Can you guys walk forward so I don't get hooked?
Everybody W key?
Okay.
You ready to nano me?
Oh, yeah.
We got nano now.
There you go.
I'm walled.
I'm just frozen.
I'm frozen.
I got frozen.
That's three dead.
We're even.
Or we're up one actually.
one we're up one but take your time zara no no stress i'm on
point you have no supports no oh wait shooting hog they
don't have heels either shoot shoot yeah zara low zara low
too if you see here hog dead where is zarya why is he's
behind me yeah one good let's go good staggers good staggers
good staggers we have cool we're gonna have uh yeah man
zarya on me it's so long jesus okay just so you guys know
this fight is a hazard coalescence combo so we has alt and
then we all engage on the people that are stunned with coal
okay like we walk forward with our more all after they're
stunned play with me right side come come come you just need
to tell me when one yeah come over here come over here
connor they're walking up here okay are we ready okay i
don't you might want to walk up it's fine we need to go you
gotta do something i use it i use needon guys use it yeah oh
yeah pole it's fat it's fat it's fat it's fat reload we
gotta look at meh she has May week, May week.
Oh, no.
That's a huge ante, huge ante.
Almost nano.
If you get farming in nano, sorry it was on me.
Sorry it was on me.
Nah, I've been fucking taken.
No!
So close.
Do we have a touch?
You just have to touch.
Maybe Bastion can touch.
I don't think so.
No.
Man, that was close, guys.
That was the closest one.
Yeah, that was really good.
Good job.
Okay, I don't think the rain hard.
better each time no no it was an attempt seeing how it goes
this character just seems so mad and angry that she is very
god yeah her nano voice line is just like her nano voice
line is just like grunting and screaming yes exactly all
right the first tab i got fucked up i think it's because
like i don't know i i position how i should position and
ring but it doesn't work i'm like i'm like this is how i
position and ring plays all supports but okay may like it
wasn't working so i have to readjust my positioning to like
our team's positioning so every time i positioned somewhere
they were not there and i was like where is everybody yeah
so i got up because i was getting individually picked
because of it and then i started repositioning myself in a
way where I knew where my team was gonna be where I think my
team is gonna be versus like how I think in rank they were
gonna be and then and then I started living yeah I was just
like I was just like I'm sorry God I'm gonna go somewhere
else I mean Mizuki hard counters Hazard hard counters Shia
and like the anti-dives are all anti-dives.
I'm gonna go and heal where majority of the people are.
That's where I ended up playing.
I was just like, oh.
I was like, I'm not getting heels off of you right now
because you're getting walled up.
Ah, I'm glad I've readjusted my positioning there in the
end.
Any other supports that would do better?
Nah.
No, I just, I feel like we need...
Sorry, good.
We're struggling with timing against Zarya.
That's it.
Because she's farming bubbles, right?
She's max charge and she has excess bubbles going into the
next fight.
How we play against Zarya is just really good timing and
really big burst fights where we're all getting on top of
her and using our form and engaging.
but because they were running roadhog may they were
essentially just playing to hook people in and they may wall
them to stay in and that's just such a corny way to play
it's just hard yeah so cheap i wasn't doing much heels on
the first half because because i was getting like people
were just getting walled off non-stop yeah i was i was doing
pretty well with taking out their supports but then after i
took out their supports everyone was else was dead yeah yeah
but like I feel like I feel like more is so good because
like even though I'm in their backline.
I'm still able to heal Yeah, no, I think you on more just I
think it helps a lot with the extra.
Yeah, we're building a cold really really fast
Chances are if we started a little hotter with hazard then
we would have won that Yeah, man, man
Me when I want to just I just need a Position myself.
I feel like I don't know.
I feel like I don't know if I should play like with my team
we should have already been at that show away from my team
ready to take a proactive fight knowing that they have they
move because at that point it's whoever i just don't predict
it so it's like if we hit a big hassle and four lessons walk
in before they grab i was just like i was just like we could
potentially get and then they have less follow-up on the
ground if that makes sense and that's a read just my brain
when it comes to positioning like hugging the first show
getting ready to engage especially last fight but then i
should not be but then it doesn't work you know i was like
but this is where i should be though i was like this is how
i would play and then i was just like i'm just gonna be with
my team that's just gonna be and then my head i'm like i
would play here but i guess we play the team that finish in
first place exactly mother wait what why is that so it's
that's it's deceiving because they don't get Usually,
usually they would get a buy, but in this one, it's they
base the last place because they get the first.
Yeah.
That's how it works in sports too.
Basically, like their reward for winning all their games is
to play, to have an easy matchup in the first round and our
punishment for losing all our games is.
Yeah.
Am I able to just go use the bathroom real quick?
No, because there's, because there's sex teams.
Yeah.
Because there's sex teams.
What happens?
Yeah.
oh what does the top two just automatically go a single
elimination so after after this uh next game we lose it's
elimination there's no losers bracket but what i mean is
like if there's six teams and they'll play each other in an
elimination then it's three versus three so there's only
three teams left or is it like the first two automatically
go through the semi-finals already in the bottom four play
each other.
I think there's a buy, right?
Is there a buy?
I don't know.
There's like a rules thing in the server.
I didn't read it.
I just saw a single elimination.
That's a...
I wonder if the top two just automatically go through and
then third play sixth and fifth feet, fourth, five, and four
play each other.
Let's see.
It would make more sense.
I don't know.
uh yeah that's the voice actor of hazard it is what it is
what it is i'm having i'm personally having fun playing
overwatch i don't know i don't know about my team
it's a live and learn experience and if anything came back
if anything maybe the next Overwatch tournament would be
more balanced.
We were the experiment group.
We were here to test out the balancing system.
This is the anything goes group.
We were to test, yeah.
Such is Hey, that's life.
You can't win them all.
That's how the cookie crumbles.
I will say I could heal more because like users doing the
heavy lifting on healing for sure right now.
I am struggling a little bit with healing just because like
my position, like my brain is fighting the game.
right now in more ways because I'm positioning myself not
very smart in this tournament I think I feel a little bad
because he's doing lots of heavy lifting for me in terms of
the heel department and also everyone is low everyone's
always low and it's freaking me out like like I'm like I'm
like please stop taking damage stop I'm like, stop taking
damage, please, they're here all low.
Just, just chill.
Just chill.
Yeah, stop bleeding out.
I think my biggest problem is just they die before I could
heal them.
They die before I could heal them.
And then I'm like, my little baby healed numbers.
Yeah, I'm just like, that's so contagious.
Use the wall.
There's a wall here.
Use cover.
Please.
That was my biggest problem.
Because then I can't heal them before they die.
I want to try, Kiri.
It's fine.
You live and learn.
I need to see the enemy with my eyes.
The wall is right here.
I would like it if my team use the wall a little bit more.
That's my dream.
All right, I just got invited.
Oh.
you guys are already here yeah we got invited first because
we're more important no that's good wait what shoto just
grabbed me out of the game i i tried to join i just got back
and i got i was like wait hold on how do i join oh okay i
could have invited you okay
if this is the last placements yeah if we win this we might
face against the second place team maybe all of most like
comfortable heroes i feel like we should try that does yolo
it yeah just yolo it if i'm down to yolo last placement
isn't that what we were already doing though uh i don't know
i don't know anymore has abdul yeah yeah yeah like zarya
ryan like that's it i mean abdul you said ryan is your main
right maybe yeah but like sure i'm down to try it but i mean
like like i'm not i'm not uncomfortable on zarya by any oh
exactly i do think zarya we were winning fights off the
zarya con even without the nanoshion which is huge if we're
winning like alternative fights with grav and maybe like
combo yeah it was a good pick yeah i will say i will say
shoto that last map might be a good opportunity to go reaper
just to blast that roadhog in the head like literally just
walk into him and just like farm life steal off him but the
passion that we're playing so it's a bit of a it's a bit of
a pickle i know it's fast it's a fast king oh my god kind of
sort of all matching player icons oh my god i just realized
they're all king uh what are we banning i'm gonna ban mezu i
can i have time to practice i'm banning mezu because i feel
like he just counters our comp way too easily against like
um we're gonna we're gonna ban mezu against sleepy's team as
well i think okay all right
here we go second last game second last game if we do two
tanks and brigitte it's like goats it's like the goats meta
we do have to keep in mind that tracer is an option here for
them oh yeah it's true i might i might go kiri maybe good
luck doki yeah i think if she's too oppressive i'm just
gonna swap to or you hit sleep like you did and um we don't
wake it my cold go back go back thursday i am playing mora
so i feel like i would accidentally wake up tracer yeah i
could kill tracer and kiri easily more like more well not
easily but more easier than i don't know okay how about this
game let's try kiri let's try it out all right let's let's
get a feel for it it is the final map before the actual
bracket so if we're dying too fast i'll swap that now yeah
the only downside is like Like, in my ultimate, I'm really
vulnerable with Alcimano.
So, it's like, it can work.
It can't.
I don't know.
We can try.
I mean, we could try Ana first round and then second.
Like, if we can't get a second map, we'll be able to kill
you.
Actually, there's an on Antarctic.
Like, some maps are better for Kiri than Ana.
Some maps are better for Ana than Kiri.
So, depending which one we start on, I'll just call it.
Okay.
Ana.
Everyone just needs to stay alive.
I need to stay alive.
there because they have a tracer player if anything i need
to see alive as a woman
true what do you what do you know is my loki warren what do
you know about this team
all right what do you know about this team i think i think
warren might be afk yeah he's typing in wants to go and play
she on again
i think they're gonna have a cloak and dagger player for
sure i want to play mercy so i can naturally be brain dead
right now back to marvel rivals
i said that in in a voice chat and then someone's told me to
keep myself safe but like games portal tech guys in
overwatch sitting here in our group chat they go to portal
and then someone was like keep yourself safe wait like not
the actual character that's just so much worse
okay yeah she said you're an ash main oh i'm never gonna
forgive her give me one moment and then that's why i don't
talk and i don't talk in vc that's we should just do like
five supports in one tank just like old times just like old
times what about first i'll tell r for my team just i'm
pretty sure we're r i just want to get that ball rolling
hear me out reinhart zarya and brigita and then never
changes it doesn't
just gonna go let's just bring it back let's just bring it
back to like season one actually let's go launch launch dive
comp let's bring it back 2017 matters okay nano blade nano
blade i mean nano blade would work nothing counters nano
blade i don't think we have a genji player team calling me
right now.
What are we waiting for?
Lucille Mercy.
Oh, okay.
Alright, we're playing now.
I was like, what are we waiting for?
How about Orisa Reinhardt, Bastion, Mercy, Anna?
I'm just gonna go with the cast character and walk through
them.
Oh, shit.
Oh, this is real.
Yeah, this is real.
Ooh, Cassidy.
We could try the Mercy if you want.
Whoa, let's go.
Okay.
All right.
Usually you cannot flank anymore.
Usually you have to heal everything.
You want Ryan or Zarya?
Yeah, I can focus on heals.
I feel like Zarya, right?
At this point.
All right.
Cause like we're not playing Ana.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes.
You're going to.
Yeah.
Cause if you're Ryan, you're going to absolutely destroy.
Bark bang.
Yippee.
I will just do what applied.
did why is this all king of the hill maps are we not because
it's fast-paced so it's around robin yeah they want like
because like we're literally i think we're ahead of schedule
right now shout out boker bash shout out boker shout out
bulgaria yeah shout out um bulgaria because he yeah let's do
this so plan of action here play a little passive wait until
i get a pick and then we walk in yeah so just don't die
early yeah don't look at the enemy team use the wall
Ana, Sierra, Winston.
So you guys go main.
I'm going to go right side.
You guys main.
We're flanking.
I'm main.
I'm in.
She's going to push.
She's not in.
Wait, can we help Shoto?
Help Shoto.
Front line for him.
Who's low?
Targets.
Winston weak.
Winston 1 HP.
He's in his bubble.
They're flanking.
Tracer and Cassidy.
Okay.
Can we keep walking through left?
Huge, huge shield.
I need a healer.
Trace it behind.
I have a monkey behind me.
He's going to push me on the left.
I'm right behind you.
I need help.
I got you.
We're up.
Push on the point.
Get on the point.
It's staggered.
Winston, if we can.
Got him.
I'm going for Juno.
Huge.
I'm with you.
I'm going to hold up with you.
Just give me drag, grab charge.
I almost have a vault here.
Oh, I'm at a nice fight.
Good fight.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
Widow low?
Is that Widow?
No, that's Sierra.
That's Sierra.
A new hero.
I have to use my flash here.
No, we can cold let's just walk for it.
I kind of want to.
Can we do it now?
Yeah.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do it.
Keep me up, keep me up.
Want Arisa?
I'm damage boosting.
Arisa low?
No cooldowns.
Ori, no cooldowns.
I'm walking still.
I'm with you.
Oh, I'm tracking.
scott bubble that's okay it's okay you can kill her trade oh
oh my resume in the room my bad no you're not i'm coming
back i'm coming back i'm raising judo though nice play
together play for grab play together it's still winnable i'm
almost back i bought a resa resa i mean when you take slow
i'm here for it that's you that's huge that's huge you are
so low you have
Oh Keeping me alive mercy.
I love you.
Good job.
Hey, it's working guys Yeah, yo, you're gonna hold maine by
the health pack and I'm gonna go behind them to shoot them
Okay, one one English English main main where you are.
You'll they saw me.
They saw me.
Okay I'm ready.
Okay Tell me when you want it one okay now now now now now
now now Okay There you go.
There you go I gave you flash heal.
I'm on a reset.
Reset dead.
I know.
Sig low.
Sig dead.
Good stuff.
Yo, just walk up.
Walk up.
I'm with you.
We have cool lessons too.
I have my own.
I got it.
We're split.
I got you.
Tracer Kataj.
I think she got through it.
No, no, no, no.
She didn't.
Ah, it's working.
Yay.
Look at that.
Good job.
The Mercy Pocket never fails.
It's working.
Yeah, except they banned my Shion.
Fun declined.
Isn't it crazy?
You're not playing Shion and we won't.
The crazy one changed to Canisaday was something really.
Okay, listen.
Listen, this is a team sport.
It's a team sport.
Okay, 13 and all.
Suddenly he gets off Shion and they're winning.
start winning okay go i have to commit listen if we're gonna
lose anyway bro i gotta at least play sihan for constant
guys it's our content farm okay content to for losing i know
for losing in the last place in the tournament corner
content for last place in the tournament is that i'm just
liking that video you i'm gonna just oh she's pretty pushed
up happy hp just getting charge here.
Take your time, okay guys?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're giving us map space.
Try not to get pushed out.
Be careful, be careful, Shoto.
Okay.
Stand on point, stand on point.
Play our side of the point.
We have the better angle.
We're matching to your left.
Be careful, be careful.
Right side we got a tracer, right?
Okay, behind you.
Good cap.
See if Justin.
I'll be there.
We have, we have point.
They have to push up.
I got a good thing.
I'll chase her behind.
I'll chase her behind here.
I'm okay.
Diva, Diva.
Everybody shoot Diva.
Trust.
She's the only tank left.
Diva.
I'm out of heels.
Oh my god.
Oh, you got bombed, bro.
Okay.
I'm low.
I'm okay.
Good cap.
All right.
I'm back.
Yo, we're going to look for early Bastion to get out
cooldowns, and then we walk, okay?
We're playing to, like, force out, like, their fly, their
fade, anything.
Hey, Bastion, can you look for all now?
Oh, Winston.
Swap to Winston.
Winston's flying, Kent.
I'm with you.
Got one.
They're on the left.
Winston, uh, left side.
Winston, do you know what?
Oh, they're all left.
They're all left.
Once they're behind.
Fall cat.
Dogs, dogs, dogs, dogs, dogs.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
More no fade.
Keep up the pressure.
They're down too.
We're okay.
They're low.
Winston 1.
Nice rise.
I'm going to need help.
Can you guys walk forward?
I'm dead.
But they're all distracted.
I'm low.
I'm solo healing.
Yeah.
Let's just play on point.
Fight on point.
Nice kill.
I grabbed for next fight.
I've grabbed for next fight.
I do not use...
Just keep fighting on point.
use anything that's huge i have grab for this so the goal is
yeah let's uh just look to gravaton don't have to overthink
it they don't have like great defensive support outs for it
drop diva now so you guys are gonna walk up you guys are
gonna walk through middle of the map like here and i'm gonna
go far left to shoot the grab okay down down let me get some
charge first tier one okay i'm
We should push in with that.
We have a pick.
Oh, I got melted.
What was that?
Oh, oh, oh.
Yo, don't stop fighting.
Don't stop fighting.
Wait, I need kills.
Send it for my colas.
Jojouik, behind.
Try to get away.
I'm trying to.
I'm okay.
Good picks.
I have a Winston chasing me around, like really bad.
Bro, that, that, that.
Got you, got you, got you.
Got you.
I'm trying to.
Yep, cap, cap, cap.
you i i don't have you i'm not with you warren i got one i
really i got you i got you i gave you flash shield sheila i
have to oh i oh my god it's got melted i got melted yeah
he's one she's like i'm really sorry i'm really sorry i'm
really sorry you're solo healing i'm in the shoe i'm in the
shoe i have all here i'm on my way from almost there almost
there i'm on point i'm on point i've got I'm here.
I'm here.
I need that like that.
I'm back.
Good pick stock grab.
Don't let them.
Are we pushing or not pushing?
We're pushing.
We're out.
Keep pressure.
Keep up.
Good res.
We're fine.
We're fine here.
Bro, I'm chasing Aspen.
I'm damage boosting you.
Yeah.
I'm going to look for Aspen kill.
I'm not letting her live.
Left side, left side, left side.
Drew.
No, no, no, no.
there oh sorry we have done it no no no no no break shield
break shield you have uh form
oh they got people alive where's their oh it's nice they
were hiding next target ona on ona everybody you're fine
you're fine on a behind the pool i'm on ram i got i got
Nice.
Good job.
We got one.
Look at that.
It's that easy.
The mercy.
I think I think that's our yeah, I think that's our yeah, I
think that's our.
Yeah, no mercy.
I knew it.
I was like, before.
hills are insane tournament began i was like what if we just
hard pocket warrior now we just do that look at the mercy
moira heels that is nuts maybe we should do that again 100 i
think it's working i don't know about work against a prize
team though but but it worked on maybe we won't be last
though yeah yeah i think i actually said that before the
tournament i know i could do the hard pocket war because
like I swear the real meta doesn't matter actual meta
doesn't matter in this in these tournaments because it's
like career tournament everyone's different ELO that's why I
was like what if we just hard pocket ward with a mercy
pocket yeah I didn't believe we should change a winning
formula because I know in the creator tournament I could
literally fly everywhere the winning formula is mercy it's
not it's not I can do the same thing on soge i could do the
same thing on ash on shion it's mercy pocket yeah because i
before the tournament i was because it's a creator
tournament so people are like in different elo i was just
why don't we just hard pocket our best dps player and just
get picks how are we going to another map against them
what's happening hey i think it's just no way their second
seed or first seed i don't think so it has to be froggy and
apply seem did they update the uh the sheet the the the goo
sheet The res that's what i'm saying you can get away with
res is i was doing stupid fucking dumb ass res is but it
works Because it works in these tournaments if i was in rink
i'd be fucking dead Like that's that's just like if we were
in the if i was in rink right now playing like that i'd be
fucking dead, but i know it will work in this tournament I
try to push it but we're like no i was like okay no no no i
don't think we're playing against these guys they're just
setting up the next lobby yeah good job guys let's go team
yay not last well well not yet we still gotta get through
the bracket well but then there'll be but then like
technically since it's single elim like all of it like
everyone's last we get eliminated so we share we share last
place so we're not the only team that's last Oh goodness.
I'm just gonna run to the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, I am gonna leave this lobby.
I knew it.
I knew I was right.
I knew I've done so many of these tournaments.
Man, it doesn't exist in these types of tournaments.
I fucking knew it.
Mercy, like I don't.
Vindication.
Yeah.
I fucking, I called it too.
I called it.
Then don't keep proven right for the hundredth time.
Should have went with my gut.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm not in the thingy.
Let's see.
They're doing a briefing right now about the thingy.
Okay, wait, maybe I'll go to the briefing.
I'm going to meet the squid.
Oh, I can't.
Actually, I can't.
Let's see.
I'm tracking to see if everyone else is in the briefing.
Okay, I'm going to mute the Discord and I have to go into
the briefing real quick.
I got a BRB real quick.
All right, I told them.
All right, I'll mute the Discord and I go to the briefing.
I'm in a Street Fighter briefing right now.
Yeah, I don't know if I'm allowed to stream it, so I muted
it.
Please, no questions.
I need to go back.
There's questions!
Here's questions!
The one guy in class.
He was like, does anyone else have questions?
Yeah, I have a question.
I have a question!
Okay.
Oh my god, there's so many questions.
This meeting could have been any.
No, it can't.
Because there's actually a lot of questions.
Come on.
ah how do we have 20 questions
Aspen was the second place team why the fuck did we not go
bursty earlier
that was the only team we be
they're like does anyone I have one more question and he's
like, I just want to say good luck everybody.
That's not a question
Okay, we're good now.
We're good All right, we're good Wait, Aspen's first place
and What did we do?
I knew it.
I knew my strow was the strat anyway yeah what are we
shaking oh what are we shaking oh our hands our hands we're
shaking hands okay well if we do lose i won't be saying
warren cost is it hey oh technically technically we beat the
first place team scoreboard oh we did aspen's team got the
buys so technically we got the strat now what yeah aspen
teams was yeah wow i knew it i knew it warren i told you
pocket was the strat i told you i don't want to see you off
mercy for the rest of this tournament i told you it was the
strat but you were like no mercy got nerfed so like it's not
gonna do much for our team i never said that i know that's
yuzu that was yuzu i did not say that you're like oh mercy
got nerfed it's not gonna do much for our team and i was
like oh my bad your mercy's your best character i feel like
in creator tournaments you can just damage boost the pocket
because meta doesn't exist in creator tournaments listen
your mercy is your best hero apparently yeah and i was like
yeah you were making a good point but then they're like that
he really wants the nano he wants to feel good for his
youtube video yeah and it's gonna look good he wants to look
at being last place i'm flipping out the defeat screens
don't worry guys look at my crazy she on play yeah yeah last
place in the tournament i'll dislike that video the moment
you posted i I forgot to ask captain.
I have to solo carry on cast.
My apologies.
Sorry, I can't trust my team.
As the highest ranked player in our team, you should be solo
carrying.
I just want y'all to know, I am the lowest rank of all the
captains.
But you're the highest ranked in this team.
No, Connor would be the highest ranked.
You know, fights.
There you go.
Are you ready?
Everybody here?
All right.
I would have definitely asked about support.
instantly i would not have made that call okay well good
thing you're a co-captain right bro you've been saying that
for three days now you could have made the call i know i
have so many screenshots of me so please let don't keep
playing i have screenshots of you going five and 11 on
hazard bro that's your character and i just can i just say
can i just say i was five and 11 in the reinhart game and i
switched to hazard i was fucking six and oh because i done
no damages right i was just fucking standing with my shield
up i said at connor you can swing bro i had to give you
permission like bro just because i'm just i'm too scared to
do anything because you keep giving everyone into trouble
they're down three people and you're holding shield in the
middle of point like bro best of one bro just i'm standing
there just like all the hoping for the best okay bait them
out we're all scared oh oh i'm beating them everybody
everybody okay there's no point me It's taking a while for
them to start the match.
Listen, everybody just gas me up on Shion.
Gas me up.
Hold on.
No.
You're such a good Cassidy.
Thank you, Shoto.
I knew someone was going to step up to the plate.
You're Shion is insane.
What?
Okay, but I will say Ruben might actually be me down,
though, on Mercy.
So, you might need to look out for flankers.
Yeah, if they are on Diva Sombra, possible or shion yeah
we'll see how it goes if it doesn't work out jim's gonna
swap to kiri because i think kiri would be better sure sure
yo we took this team to 99 i must remind y'all like yeah we
lost but it was like oh shoto i would not go reaper against
this team he's gonna be on sigma or diva i would bastion
sigma yeah sigma is like the old man um the oldest has his
toes Uh, has a melody in his head?
We can't.
That's you for some zinc for my...
What is that melody?
Who's that melody?
Here we go.
Let's go, team.
Let's lock in.
Once again, same concept.
Like, you gotta let me and, uh, Mercy do our thing.
Your thing, thing, thing, thing.
So, we'll go right side, control the health pack side, which
is over here.
I'm gonna let Hazard front line with our Tsar.
You guys walk up.
Soldier 76, that's fine.
Okay, let's walk up, and we're going to form right side.
They have Arisa, so we're going to shoot them.
Thank you.
Okay, no projected bubble.
You can set up.
Shoto set up and shooting them.
Thank you for the heals.
I need Helos main.
Jumping up.
I don't have flash heals.
We're just going to be careful.
Yeah, we get stable, stable, stable.
Yeah, you guys got a stable here.
I can't resist that either.
Shoot her, shoot Arisa, everybody, everybody, everybody.
I have Azaria on me.
Oh, Shebar.
There is a lot of damage, so you guys have to, like, peak
less.
I almost have Kolas.
Yeah.
We need to take angles super aggressively, okay?
That way, they turn for us and not our team.
I have to use flash.
You guys gotta walk towards points so they don't take
checkpoint.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay, they get it, but it's fine.
Yeah, they got it.
Oh, fuck, I jumped off to try.
They're on me, left side.
Zarya, Zarya, Zarya, Zarya, Zarya, Zarya, Zarya, Zarya.
Nice.
I got two.
Is that Risa cooldown?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I got three.
Let's go.
Arisa, Risa, Lowe.
Lovely.
They're gonna have mail soon here.
Yeah, I'm almost at Shion.
Is that alone?
Has, walk up.
Hey, they're gonna have mail.
I thought I was just so, I don't know.
They're playing here.
I'm shooting early.
We have Mercy ult soon.
Mercy ult on me.
I have Mercy here.
I have mercy here.
Just don't group up.
Almost at my ult.
We're farming for my ult.
Yeah, I'm damage boosting it.
We can vouch this.
I think we should.
Yeah, I'll vouch when the hazard wall is gone.
Yeah.
Oh, that was a huge.
Oh my god.
They're using everything.
Yeah.
They're using that one.
Okay.
I'm cool with that trade.
I was Ori, uh, grab, nano.
Mm-hmm.
They still, did they mail?
They saw mail then.
Yeah, they have it.
I've got mine.
So you and I are going to go behind them while our team
fights main.
Okay, I did not mean the email, but okay.
Are you guys ready to start moving after Maywall?
Yep, yep.
And Maywall's gone.
Jump down.
Oh, no.
Our hazard's critical.
Our hazard drop down.
I won.
We might be even now.
Okay, that's their other ults.
I'm trying to, I flash shield, I flash shield you.
Soldier and soldier ult and colus I have pilots That's fine
It's fine I realize this then We win this We win this That's
fine Yeah Good job I got her Yeah Nice job They are They
have no That's a huge They use visor and mailed They don't
have tank olds And coalesce They use cola I almost have my
ult too They should have ERISA Alt info like next fight They
could Grade Yeah they won't have it this fight Um We need to
try and get a hazard ult off here We need like a good win
Con for checkpoint I'm almost there You have no DPS Connor
Wait.
I have to use Flashy on him.
Okay, I'm here, Mercy.
I'll show it, maybe back up a bit.
Okay, can we move for Ash?
I'm purple.
I got you.
Ready when you are for all.
I'm here.
Let's go, Haz.
I'm not ready yet.
Okay, three, two, one for grab.
Okay, no, three.
Just use Alts.
Just do it.
Do it.
Don't do it.
No hesitation.
We hesitated too much there.
Fuck.
that's my bad that's my bad oh yeah we have to like 98 it
was so close it's fine sometimes fights end up like that
they will have zarya alt for this next fight i think we
might need yeah yeah yeah sorry and uh i keep wanting to
call it bongo but it is not all and then i'll carry because
of the the antis are too much yeah i think kiri will be a
good switch hey i almost have anti we need to
result here i'm main just around this corner oh i'm walled
up awkwardly it's fine it's fine i got you i got you i have
i'm gonna look to make a play let's go let's let's walk in
now i'm with you they're low on a week nice good start nice
nice more one hp if you see her oh no i need you to we're
fine thank you thank you for oh they grabbed oh damn it i'm
stopping carry now you won't have pocket we're together this
could be last fight if we don't group up group up don't are
you weak sorry weak group up here group up if you can we've
got this guys we've got this uh Warren.
Okay.
I'm on my way back soon.
I have alt.
If you guys can look to...
There's a 1 HP.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Zarya's inside.
On a 1 HP.
I'm coming back.
They're saving grab.
I almost got killed, Maura.
Yeah, this is last fight.
Can you guys touch again?
Can you tap?
Moira?
No spear.
Thank you.
Good try.
GG's.
My bad.
You know, I think if we had Cassidy there, we could have
won.
We might be right.
Ask if we can try that game one more time, but with Cassidy.
You should ask, Connor, they would do it for you.
You're literally paid by Blizzard.
You should ask.
Good try, everyone.
ggs well played ggs guys it's okay we're technically not the
only team that's last place if you think about it true it's
a tide for last place it's a tie for last do we play them
for last or no no no it's the same problem listen listen no
i know it's the same prize pool i'm just saying for the aura
for the aura for the last place or should we challenge them
let's challenge the next yes yeah
definitely the real loser is the most double or nothing how
about we give the other team whoever loses gets zilch and we
double our price i am actually down for that i'm also down
for that then we can make more money than the first place
i'm down i'd be down double or nothing guys wait actually i
need to actually propose that work please are you guys down
for double or final place team everyone needs to say yes on
cas i will make sure we will i will make like the last place
people the real winners of this tournament true what if we
lose and become the losing i think everyone i think it was
like cas mercy would have been better just for like actual
pick i don't know let's find out if it's frogger and flats
absolutely not No, it's not Frogger's team.
But maybe I should have swapped Kiri a little earlier.
It might be Aspen.
She's spectating.
What?
No.
Wait, what?
No, Aspen's second place.
I bet she's spectating right now, which means they either
won or they...
No, they got by because they were second.
Yeah.
What does by mean?
It means they don't have to play next.
No, Emong beat us, so it's not Emong.
Like, because they won majority of the game, so they don't
have to play until next round.
Oh, Toneki.
It'll probably be Toneki.
Oh, bro, they'll cook us.
not with that attitude oh yeah tony he's losing tony he's
losing i am down to risky earlier because the i know what to
do we just maybe it's a one-time thing with the anties i
just want everyone to be on board and i was like oh i should
i don't want to be i don't want to be playing with other
people's money here after i mean i do think i do think that
one i was like i'm i'm alive actually everything like we can
like you want cash is fine the only reason i actually don't
want to do it is because I was meant to be in Portugal today
and had to pay 500 quid to change my flight to play in Bogor
Bash.
Oh my.
Oh no.
That's the only reason I don't want to do it is because I
changed my flight to go and fly tomorrow and I had to pay a
fat whack so I could play Bogor Bash.
It's the only reason I'm like fuck that.
Tell Goldberg that guilt trip to him.
Essentially like I've already lost.
for that let me ask this question then to the rest of my
teammates how confident are we to the point where we could
scrounge together a guaranteed i won't play sean we can
guarantee connor to at least break even if we lose this
double or nothing granted that the likelihood of them saying
yes to this is about zero but we could ask just ask them
captain's chat right now i i can i your name's not done
it'll be bm if i ask now the thing is there might be at
least one person in their team that also says nah that and
if they say that then we're just like the video guys like if
at least if only one person in their team says like nah that
then it just means they're they're a buy and i'm a buy and
i'm down to pitch i'm down to pitch oh okay i like that i
like that connor you know what i mean so if they have at
least one person that's like i'll just take my money and run
then we could just lower the pool yeah yeah they take their
money and run i take my money and run yeah and we just and
use all play for double because i know rubin i don't know
what they played oh it was soldier may right
you'd still be playing connor don't get us wrong you're
still playing which team we're not for your money not gonna
lie that's when i'm on steam sorry yeah lose before they win
oh man a message to nikki and i say bro 500 to throw all
right disassociation time gonna disassociate it's like that
meme where the guy's mining for diamonds and then he
literally stops as he's not talking to you guys diamonds
like you have to hit the diamonds i was talking to you guys
what about the life we want it's just because they have anna
i should have swapped the moment they had anna we also
hesitated and then the thing is right what i know what
happened is we win and then you'll all be like now let's
challenge fourth place double or nothing
a nice lovely cut of 35 000 i have nothing to contribute i'm
just listening there was a lot of hesitation i will say it
should have been like best of one and whoever loses
progresses through the next round okay yeah i thought like
the quarterfinals could have been like a couple of maps and
they just want to make it fast because there's six teams
there's way too like there's a lot of teams it would have
been like a five plus hour uh tournament yeah but we are
sort of ahead of schedule because boker told me to be like a
four hour like it will be a four to five hour tournament but
we're so ahead of schedule right now it's only like two and
a half hours so far yeah
uh i just knew that some of us had to be away early so
that's why it was like oh let's just throw and then and then
let's just get away you know what i mean take our money like
um i really push the payload um game mode i come bearing
good news they they accepted they accepted okay wait wait so
now now we're at a dilemma because our was one of all of
them down or was one of them not no they all down they said
didn't we beat them and they said yeah let's do it so so
because they found out okay so that the only way we got to
do this then is if we're comfortable having zero like
winning zero no no but connor isn't connor is 100 not so the
thing is we need if we're going to do this money except for
connor's i'm i'm already i'm already out i'm already tripped
them we're gonna win this bro they don't okay if we don't
win this you have to pay connor money you have to pay for
his trip i'm down for that i'm down for that this is
warren's captains he has to pay connor the 500 he lost if i
lose this connor we're not gonna win this if you are one
foot in one foot out that's the problem bro if i if i lose
this if i lose I get both paid $750 to play in Bouguer Bash.
Care about Bouguer Bash that much.
Warren, Warren, Warren, Warren, run, run, run.
You pay him $750, boy.
You're paying him if we really lose.
You want this.
Can everyone commit to one fifth of Connor?
One fifth of Connor's prize pool if he loses, if we lose.
I gave him, I gave him.
If you're that confident, Warren, put your money where your
mouth is.
Yeah, Warren, you give them, you give your money.
I'm down.
No, no, not all me, bro.
on me not on me this is all on you if you're the captain
take responsibility we have to split connor's prizes i'm
down i'm splitting down i'm down i will give i will give a
hundred i'll give a hundred yeah if you okay 100 i'm down
with 100.
see if you see if you's run see if you's run okay no connor
it might not be 750 flat okay let's do how many people are
we five no no bro five times see if you use one as well you
just can take my price you know i don't want any price Just
walk away with my, I'll just walk away my 750, cover my
flight, my day lost holiday.
You self-split that.
That sounds lovely for you.
Can't do it.
Listen, I'm down.
Doki, are you down?
Is everyone down for 150 per person?
I'm down if Warren pays all of it.
That's not what I said.
Guys, it has to be a unified effort here if we lose.
I'm down for 150 per person.
we have to win we have to commit to this or they take 150 i
think we can win i think we can beat these guys i'm okay
okay okay okay fine fine fine okay then do it this way tell
them basically that how much are they each getting per like
like basically make the prize pool not double it's just it's
it's what we're gonna it's our team like why am i paying to
play the tournament okay i will i will ask each of them will
walk away with like 200 something or like i guess 150
actually yeah 150.
no less yeah yeah it's six ways yeah yeah they'll all walk
away with a hundred dollars they'll all walk away with 125.
bruh i am not losing a day's holiday and paying 750 dollars
to getting borgher bashed.
No, no, I would never force you to do that.
You should guilt trip borgher with that.
That's why I said the only way I'll do it is if we
contribute to yours.
Like that's I think borgher should compensate you.
I think so too.
I think borgher should 100% compensate.
Hold on.
They decided to not do it.
Borgher should compensate.
He's the one that made all these teams.
They said no, they said no.
They changed their mind.
They're scared.
We won.
They backed out of the challenge and Connor.
Maybe they were watching the stream.
Maybe they were watching the stream and felt bad.
Can we play it?
Can we play for nothing?
They all said bye.
Okay, all right, all right.
What's crazy is that means technically U5 finish in fifth
place.
And I'll take last place with the Nikki's team.
Okay.
I'll take the O with the Nikki.
That was funny.
That was awesome.
Yeah, we won.
scared of us exactly yeah i don't know maybe they were
watching one of our streams and they felt bad for connor
maybe that's not as they're like oh connor's no i think i
think i think one of them i think what has happened is
they've all went well let's do it let's do it and then as
soon as you've came out the chat war and they've all went
why the are we doing this we're gonna lose you should you
should guilt trip boker you should guilt trip boker this you
gotta talk to be like hey yo hey i canceled my trip for this
bully like yeah bro and then you can get extra i want extra
money he literally forced you like yeah you know play
overwatch worn is literally a mo you know yeah worn you
don't need the money yeah you don't need the money more you
just want your youtube content it would have been awesome
let's be honest you
not let's not beat around the bush this would have been the
best ending to this tournament ever if i kind of wish they
won me too i think that would have been so awesome fun if
warren had just played cassidy we would have won exactly i
agree rubin's team didn't go shian
i think you should pay us for first place like you should
compensate you should compensate for all I agree.
What the hell, team?
It was the worst team ever.
I'm like, man, you guys all tried your best.
You should take bogey for that.
Connor went 5 and 11.
Not our fault.
No, no, no.
We all tried our best, but did you?
Yeah, we all tried our best.
We all played.
I tried my best on Shion.
We all flexed around.
Sorry, I messed on Shion.
In fact, I tried to get you guys all double.
We would have won more money than the first place.
And I would have locked it on.
I would have played Cass and carried them a new hole.
But you could, you know, Warren, You know what you could
have done?
You could have played Cass on our last game.
That's a loser's mentality.
No, that's a loser's mentality team.
We're not losing Connor anything.
He would have gone in double.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, but we could have gotten double if you played Cass on
the last game.
If you think about that, we could have gotten double anyway.
Okay, bro, Emong is Thanos, guys.
I'm sorry, I don't know what to do.
Do you know what's crazy?
Aspen beat Emong.
We beat Aspen.
honestly i have no idea how aspen beat emong like truth be
told emong is the best player in this tournament i'm saying
because we waiter was kashian yeah honestly every game we
lost warren was on shiyan that has been the most consistent
apology from this team this has been the most consistent
part of losing warren has been on shiyan connor what are you
saying if we were so confident then been so confident one
could have walked away with his prize money to nikki's prize
money and my double prize money all he had to do was say
yeah i'll cover connor one could have been walking yeah
that's so true as the captain you should have taken
responsibility as a captain i can't oh bro that is so true
yeah because we hesitated to pay i'll say i was the only one
that was wholeheartedly down to pay the amount.
I said I was down.
I said I was down to pay my part.
And so did you, Zude.
No, don't get backed out.
Don't get said 50.
Don't get like a multi-cazillionaire.
Because I felt like Warren should have paid for majority of
it.
What?
Because I'm the best player.
No, because you're captain.
Well, you could have literally, well, you could have
literally just got me in your private jet to Portugal.
No, how about you don't go to Portugal?
How about you just don't go to Portugal?
The solution here isn't, oh.
the FIFA World Cup.
There's only one in every four years.
You know how many Overwatch tournaments there are every
year?
No, he's not even going to the World Cup.
He just said, no, no, no.
He's just going to go have a beer.
He's only going to have a beer.
The World Cup isn't in Portugal, so he's going to be.
I thought he was saying he was watching a Portugal match.
It's my brother-in-law's bachelor party.
Imagine I've actually caught a deal for this.
A bachelor party.
That's worse.
That's one of a kind.
I also said spatula party.
Okay, I wish you just went with one.
So it was it was 500.
It was 500 pounds.
Yeah.
Good to change my flight.
What is that to USD?
That's more.
That's like 600 or 700.
You walked away with this.
You walked away with like $89.
Wait, no, no, no.
It was like it was like 448 or something like that.
Wait, US dollar to GBP.
I thought he said he was watching the World Cup.
I thought he was flying to watch it.
I thought that was what he said.
That's what he said.
If I heard World Cup and I was like, oh, FIFA World Cup
Portugal.
I didn't realize he was glad of Portugal.
Just to play McLaurin.
Not even to play Cassidy or Ash.
You don't want to know what I'm thinking right now, bro.
If you went to Portugal, we would have won the tournament.
How many?
I think there was only, I don't think there was only one
other team that played Xi'an.
Everyone else played like, like their mains.
Oh, no, no.
Applies team had poke on Xi'an.
Ruben played Xi'an.
But no, Ruben was on May.
He swapped to May.
He swapped to Bay.
No, no, he was on May.
He was on May.
Guys, he played Shion all first point.
And then he realized, wait, Shion wasn't working.
And then he swapped off.
Guys, we're falling apart.
We can't end like this.
This is bad.
Team Captain, I'm putting an end to this nonsense, this
whatever is going on here.
We should just go all over.
nothing for the first place how about all or nothing one v
ones let's just run no that's fine i have a two-fighter
tournament wait what's actually what's actually technically
unfair is all the people that pulled out today are not
overwatch players and all yeah i kind of realized that too
yeah and all the people they brought in were like overwatch
players yeah what kind of conspiracy is that like they
literally killed their way i feel like it's got set up yeah
we were I swear, Bougar is a fraud.
No, no, no, can't do it.
Can't do it.
I have Bulgaria buff because I've been to Bougar's house.
So I have to defend his honor.
Okay, I have Bulgarian blood running through my veins.
Here's the thing.
He got, oh, actually, I can't say, but.
You got what?
Huh?
He got what?
He's been to Bougar's house, went to the attic, and saw all
the players that dropped out.
happened here they're all there they're all in bulgaria
right now but basically like one of them wasn't able to come
because of an emergency and then two of them just kind of
vanished and didn't tell him oh so that's why he had to
replace them one of us should have vanished too no if connor
went to portugal we could have gone on a pro overwatch tank
yeah exactly you can't blame connor he made 159 dollars and
that's not enough to have his flight just to be a part of
this tournament and you're blaming connor and see if see if
it would be different which character do you boys what a
team captain blaming blaming the guys the little guys wow
bullying the little guys right now warm voices bastion and
if we would if we would things had just been different i
could have had him long as a captain and i would have that
is so true
Captain was Eamon, guys.
Imagine that he could have taken us to victory instead of
war.
The last three days I've been messaging Warren Collins that
I said, Hey, Warren, do you mind running some games with me?
Hey, Warren, do you mind practicing?
Hey, Warren, hey, Warren.
Where were you and me, Yuzu, where were you and me, Yuzu and
Doki were playing together?
Bro, I live in a different time zone.
I stayed up.
I've been on 11-hour stream yesterday waiting on you coming
on.
The night before, I was on your stream when I'd been running
games, You're like, no, I'm asleep.
You know how you're like, oh, you want to play some games?
Well, I'm fucking asleep, bro.
I'm asleep.
You're setting the practice range practice in your fucking
Shion Bake.
You're just practicing Shion Bake about the practice range.
I was warming up.
Okay, something I wish you did before today's tournament.
Crazy, crazy.
How about you guys just go lie it's happening right now?
How about we make Aspen's team do a money pool instead?
I know...
I know in the end I did my part.
Maybe she...
I did her part very beforehand in this tournament.
Ask the first-place team to all or nothing.
That's a terrible idea.
I don't think I have the time.
I have to go to another tournament.
Why did it make sense against Tanike, wait a second.
Guys, if Doki wins the next tournament...
No, we're not winning the next tournament.
We're not winning...
I'm getting my ass beat on the next one too.
Just like this one.
beat on the next one end today and just so everybody knows
sorry let's end on a good note here we didn't get our ass
beat we went 99.99 on numerous occasions it's the last fight
we were struggling with i would be aspen and we beat aspen
who is one of the better teams so we are one of the better
teams we did we don't yeah we won we basically won is what
you're saying my i carried i carried the aspen game i'm not
going to say it out loud but i think everybody else just
came in and just didn't overthink it i think we kept
changing whereas the other teams just the changes were good
though the changes were good i think we had to change
because what we were doing wasn't working so we had to play
around with yeah like we went on or on hazard or on
mineheart that was really good i feel like the changes we
definitely played better yeah we had to play around changes
if we're not just let you play mercy at the start only one
that didn't change Until he got banned out, the only
non-flexible player on our team was surprisingly the one
with the most experience in Overwatch.
Okay, so, you're right?
Not disagreeing.
However, there's no denying.
He was more flexible and quick play than he was in a
tournament with money.
Isn't that crazy, Yuzu?
That's because he was so flexible and quick play.
I think he was playing with our money.
or you might be exactly this was a money laundering scheme
aspen is going to be funneling me money when she wins this
tournament all he was thinking about was that tick tock that
instagram clips of all is she on i'm gonna go if you ever if
you upload any clip you're all there in the comments like
this is what i'm gonna type in the comments we got last
place i'm yeah but annie's trolling is it we did it stop
first of all enough slant We didn't come last place.
We didn't come last place.
We came second last because they forfeited our dollar
nothing money match.
They said yes, we are going to do it.
And then they said, no, no, never mind.
We all came fifth except for Connor who came sixth.
Yeah, yeah, true.
And Jerome, I'll take that for my Reinhart performance.
I'll take that.
So we're second place.
No, we're second to last.
We're second last.
We're fifth place.
That's second.
You just have to, you have to, because you know how like
scientifically, you know how light enters your eye and like
it's actually upside down and then your brain.
flips it you ever heard that yeah left hemisphere becomes
your right hemisphere yeah like basically your eyes receive
all the light upside down just reflectively and then it
basically your brain switches like flips it 180 degrees so
down is up and up is down so we're second we are second
congratulations everybody on on second place it's that easy
yeah and on that note folks yeah I think we wrap up that was
that's it for me i had a good time thanks everybody thank
you guys that was so much next tournament maybe cast maybe
all right i'm gonna go get ready to get my ass beat in the
other tournament as well i did my part in the end i did my
part i will say i could have healed more in it for one of
the games i definitely could have healed more because i was
getting picked non-stop uh but that was just me being
fucking stupid and playing like thinking i was in a ring and
playing positioning in a non-ideal place but other than that
i did my part
all right i guess i'm gonna go fucking practice for the
other tournament now.
At least I don't have to rush to the other one.
I have time to actually focus up.
We won a game.
Exactly.
And that's all that matters.
It's all that matters in the end.
I mean, it was fun.
I mean, I had fun playing my role.
I don't know if the others had fun.
I think the biggest issue was just we were taking way too
much damage in general Um, so it's very hard to heal because
it's like it's like I can't out heal It's hard to heal when
they're already dead
So I was just like I don't know guys I don't know I don't
know if I should have actually just played Kiri or some shit
Because I was just like I feel like I feel like I could have
just played Kiri there in the first half um uh but it is
what it is we were set up by bulgar we were
we got set up guys our team got set up i'm joking i'm joking
though um but hey nice money i get to play free money uh for
playing a game that play off stream Oh yeah, and blame when
in doubt blame the captain.
This is why I don't play.
I don't want to be captain for anything because they're like
when in doubt blame the captain.
And what do you mean I beat I beat Aspen's team at least who
was second place.
So technically if they win it all we beat the first place
team in the end.
If they win it all.
Yeah, free money is the best kind of money.
head off now you did amazing as my support do i felt bad
because like she was healing so much and i was just like
guys give me a sec guys hold up i'm i'm trying to heal as
well guys
um and as always everybody say hydrated posture check get up
and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stood
up for me maybe stay up for the other turn in as well uh i'm
gonna go practice i guess i might make a custom later for it
so if you guys want i'm not bashing my head against rank
anymore rank rank actually makes me so mad i really i've hit
that point like the zhang like in honda uh uh for honda i
was able to play for a while because like i was having i was
i hit the what's the called i hit the um the for it but I'm
at that point where I feel like there's a wall now on my and
it makes me so mad yeah I was in a flow state yeah I was in
a flow state for it and then um and then now but then my I
was just like fuck it like I've hit a wall and I really just
don't want to play rank anymore for it any guys i'll see you
guys later anyone who plays street fighter join my custom
lobby i'll tweet about it which will be in like 10 to 15
minutes bye everybody bye